ladies gentlemen kunari elves
the other kinds of people there it is
welcome to our dragon age inquisition
live stream here on gamespot.com i'm
chris watters i'm anna prosser-robinson
and we're going to do some dragon age at
you dragonage dragon
footage oh drag ownage i see where
you're going with that i prefer
dragonage
it's got this sort of orlesian flair to
it you know uh a little elegant you got
to keep it high class here on the
gamespot stream absolutely uh so we're
gonna be playing like four hours of
dragon age so we're gonna get into it
we're gonna start right from the
beginning and do some character creation
so go ahead and join us in the chat uh
on the gamespot stream or on twitch.tv
gamespot to suggest what you want to see
and then about halfway through the
stream we will switch over to
uh the character i've been playing which
is like level five or six to see some
other areas that we probably get to
kicking it right off
from the beginning so without further
ado did you know that this menu screen
gives you like all the backstory that
you need
i did not realize that but now that you
say it because like look you got your
two you got your templars and you got
your mages
they're going to the
the con thing that like everyone gets
together and maybe conclave there it is
like let's all get together and maybe
stop killing each other or something but
then you click new game and what happens
it gets all messed up
uh and then you get right into the
character creation so
uh human you know it's funny because it
gives you a sense of urgency to create
your character did you notice that
because when that happened on the
opening screen i was like oh my god
it's exploding there's a fire i better
become someone quick so i can do
something uh so it's all for the dragon
age playable races here human elf dwarf
kunari of course you can switch between
male and female on all of them uh we are
going to
my character is a female elf so we'll be
visiting that uh i was curious i was
playing your elf and i wasn't sure if it
was male or female it was really cool
androgynous elf really yeah that's super
high fashion right now really yeah that
androgynous looks really well of course
my character creations are all high
fashion and as we're going to see with
this dwarf that i'm going to make we had
some
requests on twitter to make uh the
hairiest
uh
or a female dwarf with a beard so uh
we'll just mess around a little bit and
see what we can make before sort of
committing to a character
of course you can choose
between a couple classes the dwarves
can't be mages so you can choose rogue
like stabby rogue shooty rogue
uh two-handed warrior or one-handed
warrior that also uses two hands but to
do two different things
i'm all about the aggression i don't
need a shield two-handed yes all right
let's see
uh sure
so actually we have to i guess the
actual face
creation part happens
after we're not going to import a custom
world state uh import it happens after
like a quick quick intro cutscene uh but
before we get into this did you know
that like so i have not completed dragon
age origin in dragon age 2.
if like me
and anna you haven't done that you can
like go to dragonage.com or some or one
of the websites or maybe
dragonagekeep.com and do like one of
these bioware like
just make the major choices from the
previous games and kind of tailor your
save just before you start inquisition i
i didn't know that before i started so i
went with i went with the default world
state but you can
like do that and import it so that you
have at least some familiarity with the
big decisions that were made in the
previous two games which i really think
is awesome yeah i thought you could only
do it if you had actually played them
you could like import your save from the
previous game so that's really cool and
it's great too because it also gives you
a little platform flexibility like if
you played it on your 360 but you want
to play this one on your ps4
uh you know it'll be you'll be able to
at least have some some kind of through
line well and that's the cool offering
of this game is that huge open world and
all the different decisions you get to
make so having that be persistent is
pretty cool
uh so anytime you see some weird uh
green fart fog you know you're in the
fade
uh that's just that's just dragon age
wait no actually i don't know if you're
in the fade technically right here i
think you are
part five
it's like a cartoon fart fog
oh what's up dwarf lady so now it's
pretty
but we're gonna make her not as pretty
not for we're gonna sort of test the
limits of character customization just
so you guys can like see
uh all sorts of weird stuff so you like
you start with general and you can hop
between a few preset face shapes
uh
you know just generally we'll go for a
skinny face we're looking for the
hairiest too don't forget some skin good
hairy eyebrows
uh i so you can like
i think like nice
nice powder or would you want like a oh
ghostly white ghostly that person has
never been outside before well dwarves
you know they like to hang out
underground underground deep roads
totally make sense complexion you can
like give them all kinds of super sexy
freckles uh which honestly i feel like
there should be more freckles in video
games so i agree actually
yeah freckles are great those are some
good freckles
and then yeah you got your eye color you
got your hair presets
uh before we before you do fit i feel
like hair is a thin is it do you think
hair is a finishing touch or is it like
a defining characteristics you build the
rest of your face around well
oh
yeah got that scrolling that is like a
little bit that's pure metal right there
yeah i don't know because i kind of
built my character off the hair when i
did the canary because i decided she
needed white hair and that changed
everything i feel like you need to pick
like a tent pole
kind of feature mm-hmm that's true
that's a good point are the freckles the
tentpole feature here just build it
around the freckles yeah look this is
kind of like freckled hair that it's
like real splotchy and yeah
oh that was obama hair
look did you see some obama hair you
want to look real presidential let's
make obama as a female dwarf
i like that this this hair is just the
same hair as before only your head is
way bigger interesting i mean it's the
hair technically it looks big but it
just looks like you're skull scenario it
definitely just looks like the skull oh
so it looks like all the hairstyles
may be available to all genders that's
kind of cool these look familiar to me
from when i chose my
elf
they're definitely different than the
canary hairstyles
i ended up with cornrows canary kind of
have their own head thing going on
though
yes oh my goodness
so frosty
so frosty yes beard oh come on give me
the beard
we're just getting like white stubble
though now
because that's the kind of beard well
then we we need to have darker hair so
that just need a different hair color
yeah so we can get a beard going this is
awesome oh yeah this is what you asked
for
chat hairiest character possible uh you
know to be fair if we're going harry's
character we need some bigger hair all
right so
uh the biggest unruliest hairstyle
and you guys can tell me if you guys
want anything on
that one
yeah all right we're going with that one
you guys can tell me if you want
anything on this character and we will
try yeah 28 wants us to make eric tay
eric tay
oh man i don't know if any character
creation could capture this beautiful
specimen that is
whoa okay so i didn't mess around with
ear size before but this is like whoa
this isn't a slider this is a giant box
of different ear sizes so you can just
watch the ear morph
yeah i thought that was really cool
because this is really interesting you
know i've i've played pc games where you
can like click and drag cheekbones and
stuff like that but on console it's been
pretty tough so this system of like
here's the width here's the height or
the size or whatever it was really cool
big ears is good i think if you're hairy
you should have big ears
that's a good life tip for man of
prosperity
ear position
yeah low low and back
she's so pretty even though she has a
beard and she has skrillex hair in huge
ears listen beauty cannot be denied
that's true don't you think this is like
vaguely elf like those ears are huge
yeah those are those are catching some
wind
that's gonna maybe if she flaps them she
can fly yeah
whoa those earlobes though which do you
want want a big fat earlobe yeah
we could need to get some like gauges in
there yeah too bad you can't do like
accessories
maybe you can't access i just didn't
find it there's so much to customize
chubby cheekbones skinny cheekbones
have you ever i try to like
i had one experience with dragon age
origins actually where i spent a lot of
time trying to make this dude who i
thought was like really cool but also
like had this kind of edgy side to him
like looked really trustworthy and like
i had all these like grand ambitions
about what he would look like and like
what that would say about him but
then i ended up making a character who i
like
30 minutes in i was like oh no
i
i don't like the way my guy looks and
then it like three hours later i was
still just vexed by how ugly he was and
i think it contributed to the fact that
i didn't finish that game wow i made an
ugly character
i cursed myself it's an important part
of the game if you fail at this part of
the game
the rest of the game it sets the tone it
does right
i'm just messing around here all right
forehead
so let's now try to make every every
feature as large as possible okay all
right so i think that's super forehead
this is pretty protruding forehead right
yes
i can't see it from here but bam right
there that's a big one
yeah
it's it's always interesting to see
like what the extremes are
and then think about the developers
trying to uh
determine what the extreme should be
you can even go in later too and like
widen the eyes and you you can choose
specific colors on the color wheel
it's pretty amazing you want to giant
everything yeah
that's pretty big again like dwarves
underground you know you got to have big
eyes super wide
oh that's unfortunate
go up
this is like the periscope eyes or this
is like the
i don't know i don't i mean both are so
beautiful
up since you're closer
there you go all right
yep you're still beautiful
oh yeah get those hammer head eyes this
is
very intense tilted tilted in or tilted
out i guess tilted up like you had it is
super avatar
oh yeah get a little navi actually yeah
all right let's go that's happening
especially because the eyes are so big
yeah should we make them yellow yes
eyebrow style oh here we go oh wow give
me some options wow
wow those are majestic they're they take
my breath away
all right no just too minimalist what's
on the other end of the spectrum here we
were trying to go for the most hairy
possible all right so this this is like
meat in the middle i feel like the
center real estate is going to be where
it's decided because even though those
are pretty good though these are so
fancy they look like raven wings they do
they look like someone would get them
tattooed like on their shoulder blades
yes yeah your eyebrows inspire me i
think i shall get a tattoo of them on my
shoulder blades
eyebrow position all right oh
yes chat i can confirm this is a female
dwarf just in case anyone is confused
bob the cat lol wants to know who is
responsible for this
i like to think it's a group effort yeah
you you are responsible for this yeah
you guys all of you
who request or specifically the one
person on twitter who requested
uh
outer iris color in her iris yeah this
is how detailed it gets goodness
where where is even the outer iris
trouble seeing it all right yeah it's
yeah okay
whoa did you see it oh you can make it
like red on the outside
that's cool this is like sauron's eye
yeah
ooh i wish you could make it animated
and make animated eyes or animated
irises that would be dope
all right inner iris let's see what we
got here maybe some
you can do makeup too maybe we can make
it blue like a navi
the whole face
okay maybe not okay so should we go
yellow then
homage to
navi whoa yeah yeah yeah all right yeah
all right so we have the eyes of sauron
they do look like they're burning that
is pretty awesome nose time those is
already pretty sizable it is a sizable
nose so whenever there's like shape
that's sort of like it feels like a
general preset that you sort of start
with and you can like tweak
um
it's like this is the largest nose yes
so we're gonna stick with that
and then
nose shape
wow listen when you can't see very well
underground
scent is important it is there's an
evolutionary explanation for all of
these options i mean really we're just
trying to be as kind as possible to this
dwarf and give them all advantages in
life
that we possibly can
oh wow
wow to watch it move around
i could almost play with the character
creation for
most of the time i play this game i
could just make character after
character i just want to make gifts of
their facial features moving around and
around the room
uh
rest assured we are not actually going
to do the character creation for the
whole stream
oh like this is this one you really get
to smell your food yeah you know you
really get to experience it here
you're i don't know there's more room
for eating you can you can take bigger
bites into your face
i think we should split the difference a
little bit uh what do you think
no that looks kind of uh
like
not an anteater but you know um those
creatures that have the they're like a
tape here yes exactly yes
situation
oh yeah i got my weird proboscis
scissors down wait which one even is
this nose bridge size oh okay that's
between the eyes there's so much to
customize it's so skinny
oh
bob the cat ll says our character is
going to get beaten up at dwarf school
that's going to make them stronger
that yeah it ain't easy being the herald
of andraste all right so you know the if
you if you had it tough when you were a
kid it's just gonna help you
oh there we go yes it's just gonna help
you when you become the savior of all
humanity
all right what do you think super
prominent i think we should go we're
theming this raveny so i think that
raven type b cook
is really nice so like that that part
all right this person's name is raven
for sure
and then every time they do anything we
just say that's so raven yep just
kidding we're not actually going to play
with this character no or should we no
no no
we're going to make a kunari after this
we just want to see how weird you can
make all right nose tip position
oh tilt it up no
what do you think um
tara bostes says kill it before it lays
eggs
look she's wave she can wave with her
nose
hello
up all right you got it up those intense
eyes because again we're trying to make
advantages for this player
up would provide more nostril
yeah just kind of increases the radius
that you can draw smells from this is
really just a max character we're trying
to find the max here
wow look at that flare that is a pig
nose that's like
yeah that is wow raven pig that is
broken nose
like how broke
oh how broken is your nose wow
just watch that nose flesh gyrate
you seem quite mesmerized by this
it's
intoxicating
she's been in a few scraps his female
dwarves perhaps mouth and jaw
do tell
the oh teeth
the teeth i love the teeth all right
we're going for the teeth
showing them teeth
oh that's like no you can't give her the
fish face
super wide yeah super wide for sure
mouth position up or down could make it
even closer to the nose or it could just
bring the whole operation down a little
bit
wow that nose is a disaster
look at that thing
oh my god oh wow
intense
oh bring it up bring it up
what do you think high and tight
yeah it's a little chipmunky
uh that's true we're not making the
chipmunk we're making a pig
raven that's more raven-ish okay or
pig-ish or woman it's just more in the
theme the family yeah
anyone anyone
lip thickness
let's start taking suggestions on our
the character we're going to make and
then actually play with a little bit
which is the a kunari so this is our
sort of stress the limits and then we're
going to try to make one that like
actually looks pretty pretty damn cool
not that you don't look cool
pig raven i think she looks female
but uh
there's still a beauty about her
it's got really nice skin they're yeah
nice freckles
there is beauty in extremes nice strong
jawline yeah
that's bear that's changing the game
right there yeah actually see that not
so pretty but the big jawline you like
the bigger that does it just kind of
puts the more in proportion because
we've been going big
jowls
jowl kind of jowl action can we get here
oh wow oh so sort of like are the cheeks
pinched or are they like wow
so like
yeah how how much
lower jaw
real estate yeah
this is very specific
jowls that's a medical term yeah
um
nice channels just seem to be
pretty much disturbed by this and not
giving us much feedback what happens if
this person sits down next to you in
class what would how would you would you
say hello to them would you be
frightened i would say your eyebrows
inspire me to write poetry
damn can i just like stare at those for
a minute you're actually making the face
we've made the face so large that it's
outside the box now
we're breaking the mold yeah
yes
because the box when we started inside
the box right
double chin
oh i'm excited about double chin double
chin is an option that's next all right
hold on let's
where is this chin even going
to the left
to the right is it i feel like then
i thought this is the nose lopsided i'm
just trying to see if we need to like
balance any features out by
going to the left or right oh whoa you
literally are changing the chin from
right to left that's kind of what it
looks like
chin shape alright maybe if we yeah here
we go
strong chin big strong sure okay
ooh that underbite though
it's like under and an overbite because
you see the two front teeth still but
the bottom job protrudes
got our own little bear stand here yeah
double chin all right what
oh yeah oh yeah
that's see that's just a faction i'm
disappointed i wanted i wanted like
full-on fold you know
you wanted a separate line
yeah like you know i can't i can't do it
right my husband can do it really well
he he likes to show me how he can make
himself have a double stick
it's really romantic it's super it's
just the thing we do yeah
you know and then it goes away and
you're like oh yeah oh
that's a little too far
i don't know
it's never too far okay it's never too
far matt massive chin adam's apple
but she okay so this is the one
oh my goodness it's like a tiny little
chip look at that thing
it doesn't look like shrapnel or tuning
this is interesting because
adam's apple traditionally an identifier
of males yeah but maybe female dwarves
have adam's apples i don't know that
just looks like a rudder or something it
looks like a pin you're a boat yeah
i think we're just gonna have to i don't
think we should give her an adam's apple
i think that although we're going for
biggest of everything that would
make her
more male identifiable than females all
right so this is our female dwarf
proceeding very well if i do say so
myself gorgeous what do you guys think
uh ninzard says that they bet she has a
beautiful singing voice i bet that's
true oh yeah i bet that's true
um
okay well people are pretty much ready
for take two so i guess quick scar scars
or an unmarked face scars for sure
a lot all the scars all the scars max
scars
super intense super intense scars oh god
wow that oh that is vicious
that is
did you hear from the production room
that is mean oh yeah we can just move
them all around ah look at this this is
disturbing this is the paint oh the nose
the nose is totally broke for a person
totally broke nose okay we haven't even
given her a name oh raven raven was her
name yeah so vertical position
nope that has to sit right over there
yes
bro what's up that is a beard
do you think that she got some tattoos
because she was like uh these scars were
there were tattoos i totally missed
tattoos wait you didn't get your
lightning bolt down the nose look i wish
whoa that one is scary
that one is definitely weird all right
that
oh did you see i didn't even notice the
lips on this yeah that's what it was the
like stitched lips it's like a that's
like a skeleton yeah all right we're
just gonna go with one of these guys
and uh
you can color the tattoos too yeah like
a nice purple oh why didn't i do a nice
like lavender you can't customize your
character after you make it right no i
don't think so that sucks
and then you can go into all this eye
shadow stuff
i
this is not my specialty under brow
color
under brown color i wish i think there
is there a blush color because we should
definitely make it blue
okay uh eye shadow no no down down down
eye shadow goes on your eyes okay blush
color yes blue blush yes
the homage continues blush intensity
yes wow
she's a painted lady
oh wow what are we going to do give her
some like taylor swift lips
so taylor swift raven pig avatar
oh yeah
green or purple eyes no we already did
eyes we'll do green and purple eyes next
lip liner
oh wow oh wow
this is this turned bad
uh this got real bad yeah the makeup
text says their eyes are dying i think
it may be time okay we move on all right
uh if you back out you will lose all
changes to your character's appearance
goodbye
avatar taylor swift i think we just want
to start
because we have to like restart new game
i think this will just restart the
yeah this will that's where we started
from but
that's what we started with oh yeah
well i like what we ended up with better
great accept
uh
are you trying to go back to main menu
yes so you have to like finish that
and then
oh i see it shows this cutscene part
which we'll show when when we make our
kunari
don't look dope right now
we'll do a quick qunari uh make and then
we'll get right into it to uh to play
some dragon age including proper with
the whacking people with stuff and the
intrigue
intrigue that's what i was looking
forward to most this game is rated m
for
blood intense violence nudity sexual
content strong language and the end
there's intrigue in this game all right
i can't spoiling everything
quit
we're gonna start again this is this is
me using the connect
quit start start it again
let it start again
all right it has to like shut it down
and now it's like okay now we can start
again
character creation very powerful yes
dangerous some might say i think that
character creation is more fun when
you're doing it than when you're
watching it i think
wow majeko wants to know is that anna
poser no this is the real thing baby oh
yeah the real thing no we checked her uh
birth certificate before the stream i
have to bring it every time i come to
gamespot it's pulsing
cbs policy all right don't ask me
ask two brokers yeah
uh they want to know if we're playing
this at our mom's house is this your
mom's house is this
it
no no no not my mom's house not mine
either good guess though
all right uh i see some calls in the
chat that like you guys really want that
quick that i mentioned to be quick so
it'll be quick uh two-handed warrior do
you think for the qunari
that was your jam yeah although
i did like the range
yeah uh male they wanted the prettiest
male qunari okay prettiest male canary
let's go we'll make chris waters qunari
it's the prettiest yeah
like if i had giant horns
cool
followers and then so it like tells you
about a little bit about your backstory
here uh
you know you
you're a kunari i don't know much about
them
they're giants with horns okay they
um
follow or don't follow an ancient
religion
i think that we do like most of us
follow don't follow or maybe somewhere
in between
yeah
uh so but i believe it it dictates that
we do not follow that really ancient
religion okay i think we like definitely
like an ancient qunari religion yeah
because and then it's like because a lot
of this game is like oh the [ __ ] i think
yeah that sounds right
uh a lot of this game is you basically
dealing with the fact that
or a theme throughout dragon age
inquisition is you dealing with the fact
that like a lot of people think you're
like the chosen one who can like
come and shut down the horrible rifts
that are spewing demons into this
earthly realm
ooh
he's already pretty he's already really
pretty he is really pretty all right
we're just going to pick a general head
and make like maybe one tweak where are
your horns
obviously not that one no
uh which horns do you like i kind of
like that i like our first guy this
guy's really pretty yeah should we just
go with it
yeah i like him all right i like him
just the way he is cool
karas i would maybe put a tattoo on him
maybe all right we'll give him one
tattoo and then we'll be on our way i
really like the tattoos
i apparently didn't scroll down make up
scars you don't want to give them some
lip shine
did they not i get tattoos i thought it
was scars maybe that's why i didn't get
tattoos because kunari don't tattoo
themselves
i guess that's because you can
customize the horns so much
okay we at least have to look at
different horn options before
uh what maybe it's in hair i think it's
in hair
general oh horns
we're going to stick with the first one
because these are dope unless we see
ones that are much doper whoa those are
pretty dope oh they're like polished
that is that's that's a little more
pretty yeah that is pretty yeah and he
has hair with it but then we'd have to
go into hair color and stuff no
oh yeah that hair is kind of grody this
hair the cornrows is pretty dope that's
the same hair i put on my lady canary oh
little mohawk style stick i like that a
lot it's not necessarily pretty but i
like it mohawk is the front runner now
that's pretty yeah do you want bling on
your horns or
i like playing horns this one's got like
a mother of pearl
like cameo or something
all right
all right i think i moved around i like
the mohawk
i like the first ones and i like the
bling ones with the ponytail but we'd
have to change two options well i gave
you three so now you pick one i don't
remember what they were oh his horns are
gone now oh
oh you can have like real sad broke
horns
that's cool i like that one let's do
that one but just change the hair to
well do we need to change the hair i
mean gray hair
you like the gray hair are you like a
little darker or like
making blonde blonde flowing locks
like a red
no like golden blonde
where you were like one of those
yes that is golden look how beautiful he
is
yep there it is
my husband has a blonde ponytail maybe
i'm
he's gone hey you've got a type i gotta
make
where are your horns where are the horns
i feel like we've been grossly misled
what'd you do you made it right i didn't
do it there were horns in the picture
this is the same mistake you made last
time you made a character that's going
to dissatisfy us for the entire year
at a vital part oh
slight
it wasn't me it wasn't me damn it maybe
it's you guys can all vouch for me i was
watching you were watching it was
definitely chris waters
i'm so sad about his horns yeah me too
but what are we gonna do
quit the game against i mean
the vikings says they show up later on
what you better be right i hope so you
you are a prophet of good if that's true
why would they show up later on
i don't know i think that there was a
slight uh
bug
don't look at me like that
i think you just messed up and i think
you're trying to blame it on someone
else and you need to just sit there and
think about taking responsibility
i wanted those beautiful horns as much
as you did okay good maybe they'll grow
says
shorty rocks
horns grow
you have good eyes you can read that
from there
yes also i recognize that username
because that dude uh is hangs out and
chat a bunch
because he's cool
that was right i met him i met him in
real life i can't do that cool thing
well you're not off naughty obviously
i don't see horns no
we've been betrayed
this is why we're in you know what
they're broken off this is gonna shape
our character creation uh we thought we
were getting horns
there was a small bug and we didn't get
horns it definitely wasn't my fault
i think we can all agree well now we
have a chip on our shoulder because our
beautiful horns got broken off so that's
that's going to inform how we make our
character dialogue decisions
because like you can be kind of sweet or
like oh i don't know what's going on
this guy's going to be aggressive he's
going to be like shut up go beat you up
tell me why we should with my lack of
horns all right so this is cassandra
uh
everyone who would say she
is
accepted
has arrested us
and they think that we have done
something to cause this giant explosion
this rift that is bringing demons and
all hell into the world because
basically it exploded and in the middle
of a peace summit between the templars
and mages and now the potential for
bringing that war to a close seems
distant the the holy woman who was going
to bring it all to who's going to
brought everyone to the peacekeeping
table
is missing or dead and
uh let me go
and somehow they think we were involved
because
in the wake of the explosion we were the
only we just were there in the middle of
the explosion with our hand glowing in
the same
as you put it fart fog as
as the wrist itself yeah so uh
cara's getting some guff
can we turn on subtitles yeah that's a
great idea
as soon as this is over yes it will have
to be after this brief cutscene
they don't give us many body
customization options but that's because
the canary have to be big giants
yeah the customization of mostly is
oh he's so pretty
except for his horns
that just makes him all the more
beautiful broken beauty he's he's been
he's been through some stuff he has
for real this world has not always been
kind to cara
is it rob i don't think there's a t on
the end oh
damn what is that thing look at his
beautiful eyes it's a massive rift into
the world it does have lovely it's
larger with each part of gray eyes
it's not the only such rip
just the largest
berserker camara we will be streaming
for four hours so until 2pm pdt this one
did
i think it's just
pt
specific daylight savings
that always confuses you
my hand
the rift
oh each time the breach expands
your mark spreads sandra thinks we may
be involved
it may be the key to doing this but
there isn't much time
i still can't
put on subtitles yet
he's angry
so i don't really have a choice about
this oh she disapproved
yeah you go ahead and disapprove i've
been through some stuff i lost my horn
look at my head man back in 98
it was a real rough time
back then we didn't worry about rifts
look at all these no horn having people
just like them now
bigger and way prettier
head of the chantry the conclave was
hers
sandra i wish i could hear what you're
saying to me
i think it's aggressive
and i think you disapprove of their
leaders together
now they are dead
cassandra's pretty upset
we lash out like he's taking us to the
conclave beyond ourselves no man the
conclave is what got blowed up until the
breach is sealed
she's now
we're like a
prisoner of hers
yes but there will be a trial
i can promise no more
so she thinks we might be able to help
so she's cautiously trying to bring us
to help them yeah she's like all right
all right so we're gonna put on
subtitles real quick
so you all can read up on what's going
on while we're maybe chatting a little
bit enable subtitles
and then crimson we are playing this on
xbox one
currently
conversations and ambient or just
conversations
let's do the whole thing let's see let's
see how it goes yeah firm changes
so many options in this game must be
tested on something smaller all right
hold on i also want to remove the
tutorial uh
messages
enable persistent gore yes
that mature rating
so you can customize a lot of what it
looks like except where's the
it's not going to be an audio or control
this is getting totally annoyed annoying
to you guys so we're just going to play
through the tutorials
i'm going to the right
this is actually one of those moments
where like
you know you can run full speed by
inclining the stick all the way but
i like to like just do like the
the slow walk
kind of like pan up and like start to
take in what this game looks like
because it looks really good a lot of
these environments are really pretty
um and also
you know i feel like
this is this is like a character moment
too you're like i'm gonna go there on my
own time i'm not in a rush to get
wherever you want to take me lady who
imprisoned me for doing nothing
yeah i'll get there when i get there but
for the sake of action let's get off to
the races
i was wondering too because this is just
a giant open world whether i could just
run off into the forest at this point
and just be like screw you guys
but it's pretty hard to get up that
frozen cliff face the answer is no yeah
there and later on once you sort of uh
get loosed into the world you can uh
start
oh no
my hand
ow
the rift
getting totally rifted right now
the pulses are coming faster now
she cares about me a little bit i think
so even though she disapproves of you a
little
actually not even the little she just
thought it disapproves
stepped out of a rift
then fell unconscious
they say a woman
no one
well this is also an important plot
point is sort of she's basically saying
what we told you guys is like we fell
out cara fell out of the rift
and then a woman was seen in the rift
with us
uh that was the glowing woman you saw in
the intro cut scene while we were still
lamenting our lack of horns
uh or was it a woman
damn oh
crap
god i wish
stay behind me
give me a weapon
uh-oh
yeah
i'll pick up that giant sword
awesome
may not have horns but i have a giant
sword just gonna whack you with a giant
sword a bunch
hold the right trigger to continuously
attack hey come back here wait i was
continuously attacking you what do you
think the x power is
boom what is it oh super clobber super
clobber
it's probably
not technically called that's over
drop your weapon
now
i need that's my bad hell no a demon
attacked me what was i supposed to do
you don't need to fight
are you saying it won't happen again
you're right
you're right called it
and i cannot expect you to be
defenseless
cassandra's awesome
just killed this demon totally
reasonable with you as a prisoner
i'm into it
oh yeah
big time
got a cool break the braid that seems
like it would be really difficult to do
i don't understand how you just make
your hair into a circle of hair on top
of your head
i'll get you some hair extensions we can
make it happen
you think that's what it is you think
she just wears someone else's hair on
top of her head
i mean i don't know i don't know what
they did back in the dragon age loot
loot
yeah give me that rashvind vitar i think
that's the vitar is something that the
qunari wear
uh but
really i think so yeah so let's check it
out i think it's arma he has horns in
here
right
there are totally horns here i told you
i chose one
we were both wrong
you're right there's an s on the end
damn uh okay we're just going to play on
this screen from now on because it's a
world where we have horns
uh so a vitar
is like
gonna go
on our shoulders or something it's like
a i think it's like a helmet
because it looks like it looks like a
helmet so let's just see if it shows up
on his head
nope
i actually have helmets because you can
so you can set helmets
to be viewable or not viewable
so you can see your beautiful face
exactly but still have the protection of
a helmet
i think that's in case control is not
gonna be under control
i swear to god that i chose this but i
never never i do remember seeing that
you're not crazy
i don't know
it's okay i want to see these beautiful
golden locks a lot of different parts of
the stream seem to point to the fact
that i
do not have good memories of things that
i did
look at me drop it through the snow
trump trump trump i gotta leave
footprints everywhere i go they are
giant because i am a huge
kunhari dude
yeah give me that iron i'm just gonna
pick up this friggin rock wow you're
already scouting for things oh yeah in
the midst of your origin story
i totally am
dear mom i'm gonna press the shout at
shout at the devil button oh mighty
blows that's what super smash is called
you want to get mighty blowed
bam have you been using any the lock the
target lock on there's so many combat
options in this game it's really intense
shadow essence
creature research item oh hey dude you
want me to help you smash this thing
sorry sandra
interface
for the horns wait what oh because our
horns aren't visible because they're a
helmet
interface interface hideout helmet so
okay well let's see let's just see we're
going to confirm those changes will we
have horns
no
no it's just
the vitar i now have paint on my face
interesting so that's that's the qunari
version of a helmet i guess
right there he is there's your tiny
little head well paint on my face is
cool i dig that
it's pretty boss uh yeah so you can
actually in character record you can go
in there and like look at the names and
all the stuff about what your abilities
do but that's locked currently during
this introductory sequence so instead
i'm just going to like
taunt this thing
james i missed we may not have gone
through puberty yet that's why we don't
have our horns i don't know man
those
horns look pretty broken yeah i think so
it was a good theory though good try
what
ghost get back here
i keep missing with that strike
so what's the the auto targeting it's
only it's when the little uh little you
can start things press down on the right
joystick and then it'll lock onto one
all right i'm gonna have to do that a
little more often because i was missing
a ton and felt really dumb because i was
like
slicing over here battle time
ice is cool looking
oh yeah now i'm locked on
coming for you nope uh oh fine uh enough
i'm gonna attack this guy
boom
i don't think you are lost on that now
you are you're locked on him
i'm switching between targets by tapping
the
analog stick left
that was just a little overkill there
for you just a little extra
here i come to
taunt you guys
what's up nerds
i presume that's what he says when he
taunts
something similar
is that you being talented are you
taunting that no that was one of my
moves that's my that's on my why oh uh
button when you taunt does that mean
they just can't attack someone other
than you yeah it pro and i think it
gives me a boost to uh my attack ah uh i
would guess or maybe some kind of i need
a potion
um
no drink that
yeah quaffed
scrood wants to know if we're playing or
are willing to play with friendly fire
on i didn't even know that was an option
i would not play with that on personally
where i could like accidentally clobber
cassandra with a sword uh i don't think
so i don't know if that is on but i
could not turn it on yeah why why would
you turn it on is my question do you
like if you want to play that super hard
the tactical challenge of trying to like
position your archer in a way that
you're not blasting uh your buddies
maybe i definitely took a shot last
night where i shot a mega arrow right
through one of my teammates to get to
the demon yeah i guess it'd be a little
more realistic
over here jerks although they yeah this
one is taunted so it comes right for me
yeah like i just would have killed i
would have killed like three civilians i
mean i guess they're not civilians but
three of those guys
oh what's up very cool ponytail
talk to the hand
the rift is yours
you mean this
whatever magic opened the breach in the
sky also placed that mark upon your hand
i theorize that mark might be able to
close the rifts that have opened because
he has a big stack and it seems i was
correct
it could also close the breach itself
possibly
it seems you hold the key to our
salvation
what good will it bring back my heart is
rogue storyteller and occasionally
unwelcome
so i was reading kevin van gogh's review
of this game which he gave at nine
uh hold on nine that's a solid review oh
yeah that's great uh all right
you're with the chantry are you with the
chantry or
was that a serious question a nice voice
too technically i'm a prisoner just like
it is i see that now now you can't unsee
it i know actually i didn't notice
before but now it's the focus i'm down
with this dude though that's a nice
crossbow you have there yeah
ah isn't she
bianca and i have been through a lot wow
such a pretty little love shot oh yeah
that's the tender moment of course
and she'll be great company in the
valley
absolutely not
your help is appreciated varric but have
you been in the valley lately seeker
your soldiers aren't in control anymore
you need me
that's a pretty big time
that he's got on how's that my name is
if there are to be introductions well
you're saying you used to wish we had
some uh accessorizing yeah he has
earrings why couldn't we have earrings i
totally agree
i can't close the breach if i'm dead
that is most certainly true solid logic
cassandra you should know the magic
involved here is unlike any i've seen
your prisoner is no mage
indeed i find it difficult to imagine
any mage having such power
understood
we must get to the forward campaign
you know what's coming up
oh battle time
bianca time
he's kind of leaning with his head over
which is something tall people do
because they get tired of hitting their
head on things
do you know this from experience i have
sometimes done that myself he's also
talking to a dwarf who's like yeah
let's do this
you guys got to get into it too yeah
eric you got up so you can like jump as
high as you are totally oh yeah sick
vert man us
dude so yeah this now that we have a
party
we can uh switch between party members
and play as them and what have you so
i don't know do you do that much have
you done that much you know i was doing
it running the battles cassandra
i didn't run into battle i was staying
mostly as the herald but then
there's this tactical battle mode that
it just
introduced i was using that a lot during
like boss fights yep
so what you can do here if you're
unfamiliar with it is you can basically
give orders to each person like you
defend so-and-so you attack so and so
you interact with this yeah
and then you advance time by holding
down the right trigger which is cool
because
i felt like i could get my whole
strategy in order and then advance time
just as far as i wanted and then change
things up like i want cassandra to bait
this guy so like all right you're gonna
give him the shout challenge him
and then
meanwhile
you're going to try
karas
i want you to come and
super smash this dude
mighty blow sorry this is not called
super smash you look like you have
already fired varrick is that true no
not quite in the process uh yeah i
wanted to knock this guy out and then
everyone focus on the
boom
long shot and then solas is already
casting a barrier on all of us so now
we're gonna like
also like the freeze frame lets you see
them in like cool moments like solas is
already casting a spell camera movement
oh yeah yeah like
karas is pulling out the sword cassandra
that braid mmm the braid all right let's
see
so like it happens instantly there's the
shot and like you can freeze it and see
like the tracer for the shots just like
blasting into this guy and you're like
oh god take that horrible abomination
thing
and this is
this is like her shout out look at it
which is kind of like banshee style from
like x-men like you see the like ripples
in the air yeah around her face and
stuff
see this is why this game can take so
long for me it's not good for a stream
but i can sit here and just look at
things just check it out yeah yeah
because like now i've i'm just letting
go of the right trigger to to advance or
not advance time
and how's this lesser shade doing
uh
almost dead
karas you're gonna you're gonna do some
basic attack on them oh no you're still
waiting to land the mighty blow let's
see the mighty blow oh
boom shakalaka
all right that thing's dead
now everyone focus your attacks
carlos i want you to talk war cry this
guy
and then you're shield walling that's
dope you guys have already spent all of
your
so he's got caltrops he can like run up
and
throw down but i think we're just gonna
shoot yeah these guys are kind of small
potatoes they don't need to
get too technical yeah because they
they'll be easy so now the [ __ ] like the
shade goes down on the ground
and he's like
chilled and it's like oh you're
vulnerable everybody strike with the
hammer of a thousand
hammers damn it so we messed up that
metaphor
then you can just switch back into like
real time whenever you want
keep beating this guy up and then
run over here
i should have been more switching
between characters like you're doing
that would have been fun
there's still time unless you've beaten
the game already no i have not i
unfortunately did not have 90 hours to
spare between monday and today
uh so then you know like even though
this is this is a pretty linear start
like because you're just sort of you
know getting you're making your way to
one specific place in the scripted
sequence there's still like
you know
this little burning house that you can
totally run into and
loot some stuff
you gotta know that this is probably a
time of gl great calamity for you all
but i need this 44 gold
i need to walk through this fire to get
uh
62 gold
this is why i have no money
i got no money because i did not loot i
was too busy running into battle oh you
got a loot
listen
i'm listening
listen a rift's got to get close
but
you also got to get paid i mean yeah you
know
it's like a bad precedent to do it for
free exactly it's like those merchants
that are like
hey it's wartime and everyone's starving
why are you charging me for food
isn't that kind of selfish no man just
because it's wartime doesn't mean that
the whole economy is just going to
collapse all right
you understand like people need
to buy stuff capitalism has to continue
absolutely
oh yeah
big sword fashion so yeah like
i started to get better at tracking my
like
started to get better at tracking my
health like a little later on
that was a tough part for me at the
beginning too especially like tracking
everyone's health cassandra kept running
into people and just getting
you know sliced on and i had i would
have to move her
are you yeah are you so are you playing
a melee class predominantly i think
i'm like are you in there swinging a
sword at someone's face yeah but i'm i'm
the one
the kind of ranger that has like i can
either be ranged or have hand weapons
like i have daggers oh okay
yeah i'm playing with yeah see like the
character i started playing as i've been
predominantly being an archer lately
like at the beginning so i'm mostly away
from battle but then with varric also
being an archer and then
uh
you know solas being a mage
there's like it's only cassandra going
in there to like take all the hits on
the chin
uh so
and she has
trouble but i haven't figured out how to
effectively use that against some of the
demons
oh so then when there are rifts around
these things will spawn demons
you can use your mark to uh not only
close rifts which is what you're doing
now
once all the demons that it spawned are
dead but um
you can use it to disrupt the rift which
kind of like
damages all the demons in the area
leveled up nice well yeah
all right now we're going to get some
skills some head whacking skills
so here we are uh getting totally
taunted because look they're
definitely oh wait we can't see the
character come on show me my character
they're definitely horns oh he has horns
oh it's brutal
and then crimson is mentioning you can
actually revive players when they die
that was a cool thing true yeah yeah and
as my
archer which we'll see later i have a
stealth like turn invisible ability and
so that's really helpful for reviving
because you just invisible run around
all right so mighty blowed is just extra
damage and then
use on incapacitated foes for a combo
uh war cry
taunt it taunts all the nearby enemies
and you gain guard like like a shield
basically
so there's like guard which i think is a
physical shield and then barrier which i
think is a magical shield
not 100 sure on that um
but yeah it provides protection and it
must be broken before you take damage so
that's a good one to
once you're in a group of enemies do the
war cry because
if there are enemies there uh you get it
stacks for how many nice uh you get so
since we're going two-handed uh let's
see what we can unlock here so
okay yeah i got it thanks
in each of the ability sort of paths you
have there's like four for each uh for
warrior rogue or mage
um
and oh cool so you can kind of pick all
right i want to be a tank so i'm going
to be vanguard or i want to be the big
damage dealer
yeah so some of them and you kind of
spread yourself around a little bit
between them eventually because like
there's not actually that many skills
and i mean this one's a pretty long tree
but like
you're gonna get more skills than you
can unlock here uh so
i want another ability because i only
have two
because you can so like i could upgrade
mighty blow to do extra damage and uh
reduce the cost of it
but shield breaker this is a passive
thing i believe
your critical hits
sunder the enemy's armor
uh which is good but we haven't run into
too many armored enemies yet
indeed so i think
you stand ready to deflect the next
incoming attack and deliver a punishing
counter so this is i'm gonna unlock this
one because it seems kind of interesting
it's not
a direct attack
it's like i have to it's kind of like
almost like
i don't know like
it feels like it's out of like one of
these like assassin's creed or arkham
asylum things where you like see when
the enemy's attacking
parry and then you can do an extra
damage combo that's what it sounds like
let's see i don't know if i'm gonna be
able to use that uh yeah i was wondering
because i use the the tactical view a
lot and so then it's tough when you're
just assigning things to do it's tough
to find those moments where you can
actually parry or block or things so
maybe switching back and forth between
those two views would be the most you
stand in the corner go in the corner you
just didn't return you hey i was talking
about it i'm leaving
go back in the corner archer
stand there
i'm sorry i have a lot of issues my
horns are missing it's making
someone was asking about healing i i
don't know what you were asking viggi
nash but you can you have healing
potions that you could administer during
the game as well
and refill them i don't supply cash yeah
so you've got potions i
have not
unlocked an ability that's like
you know a healing spell or anything yet
for solas
uh but i can't i have to imagine that
there are
definitely some something along those
lines of that
yep i'll take that fire staff and you
can manage your
like your teammates uh
inventories by going to inventory as
opposed to character record you switch
between them so like solas
i just picked up a fire staff
you are currently rocking an ice staff
so
it does like a smidge more damage and
gives you more willpower
i'm not 100 sure what willpower governs
because i don't i have not yet found
like where it sort of describes that
stuff and his barrier seems really
useful so i would leave him on ice
codex oh cool the barrier is definitely
useful uh
tutorials magic so this is all like
you're unlocking stories in background
um
like this tells you about status effects
this tells you about the character
record this is all the sort of tutorials
that i've seen thus far
i kind of wanted to find one on like
attributes but this is just on
characters
is it in journal no that's quest stuff
character record this is all of your
look at our beautiful horns attributes
maybe this represents how we see
ourselves in our head like when we when
we go and level up this is like how i
look in the middle yeah this
i'm i have the horns again they have
majestic
uh all right so here's the different
attributes so
this is
increasing attack and guard damage
bonuses physical strength
uh dexterity is agility reflexes and
coordination oh so the dexterity
increases attack for rogues strength
increases attack for warriors
magic increases attack from mages
and then
cunning increases range defense and
critical chance for everyone will power
increases attack for all classes
and magic defense
and then constitution increases health
and melee defense so
for looking at the
uh
his
uh staff situation again plus 6
willpower is going to increase his
attack
but
the dps he's going to do is still just
29 so
i do like that barrier damage bonus i
would stick with the ice one for now
cool cool cool cool
guys don't worry about it nope it's fine
put put your put your sword away it's
cool talk to
leliana
olol the game can be multiplayer but
we're not showing that today we're just
playing the single player
it's like a horde mode i hereby order
you to take this criminal to valroy oh
to face
you are a execution
clerk a bureaucrat get him cassandra you
are a thug but a thug who supposedly
serves the chantry
we serve the most holy chancellor
as you well know
justinia is dead
we must elect to replace all right
i think you're wrong i think we saved
her in the rift standing right here
don't talk about me like i'm not here
yeah get ready
how
you won't survive long enough to reach
the temple even with all your soul i
think you're wrong
it's the quickest route
but not the safest
our forces can charge as a distraction
while we go through the mountains
we lost contact with an entire squad on
that path it's too risky
listen to me
abandon this now
before more lives nope
probably not
come on man look at that thing
look at my hand you think i'm gonna
abandon this fart fog is coming
how do you think we should proceed
how do we want to proceed uh so i took
the mountain path previously i charged
with the soldiers oh how'd that work out
for you
uh pretty well
so this one it gives you a little bit of
a breakdown of what each option is going
to be
fast but indirect soldiers will act as a
distraction elsewhere the problem will
be addressed sooner but there may be
casualties whereas charging with the
soldiers through the valley is careful
sustained assault soldiers will stand
with you to ensure arrival scouts in the
past may be lost mountain path sounds
more fun actually cool let's do the
mountain pass should i give him some
sass first yeah sassem sassafrassy
and you are the one we must keep alive
since we cannot agree on our own
it's got an intense look right now yeah
we will take them outside
cassandra is kind of disapproving of us
but she keeps being nice to us varric
approves now he's down with it eric and
i are going to be buddies
with our ponytails
that guy's a tool
he doesn't even have horn stubs
thanks judo cho
p james he says we're doing a great job
mountain pass you guys like climbing
ladders because it's about to go up
it's a little louder humor there for you
it's good yeah best louder jokes
i'm sorry about that one this is fun i
didn't do this last time
all you have to do is tap a to climb a
ladder you don't actually have to hold
up whoa
yep figure that one out elite strats
coming at you this is a pro whoops
dragonage player right here
that kind of european situation
these ladders are remarkably sturdy for
being on the side of a giant mountain
the one thing i didn't like about
playing in qunari is they seem really
slow when you run it's like
let's get a little skybox pan here
oh yeah
it's going down over there
wow that silhouette majestic look at
that oh i can't get the camera low
enough so we're just gonna have to go
with like that this is why i love this
genre because this is all i really want
to do is just look around and be like
i'm in a fantasy world and i'm so
buffing
cool oh yeah it's cool i'm just going to
walk in here keep the camera on my face
so i look badass i don't care what i
find oh god there's a bad guy
i don't know
get shouted at oh that was your shout
yeah that was my war cry all right i'm
going to try my deflecto thing on this
guy
oh yeah
nice yeah
i thought that was pretty well if i do
say so myself let's do it again come on
come on
if i had to do over i would definitely
get that big sword that was cool
that's the great thing about video games
you can do them over that's true
wow that was unnecessary i understand
that he was dead already
oh you're like streaming pretty magic
behind you yeah i got bare i think it's
uh the barrier that soul s puts on me
helping helping the team out he's a team
player wow bust robot pulling out the
lore says if i recall correctly
cassandra originates from nevada which
is the dragon age equivalent of medieval
spain
yeah
dropping those knowledge bombs
i believe it
i wonder i like her so much
all right what is going on in here
giant stalactites
is that so like yeah because they're
they have to hold on tight because
they're at the ceiling so like mites
might reach the ceiling ah that's a good
way to remember it uh mine is the
spelling centric one stalac have a c in
it for the ceiling and stalag have a g
for ground wow yeah
that's less cute though definitely less
cute
bamboo
wow
pounding them into the ground
yeah that was my uh
super super pound
mighty blow mighty blows what it's
called
i hadn't seen it do that before
i keep trying to get my like uh just
hairy boom yeah the perry isn't going
but
not super ace at it yet
all in good time
so it seems like for these lesser
battles you're mostly staying as our
main character and then in the big
battles you're switching between
i
rarely ever switch between really yeah
but we can mix it up we can uh next
battle let's go is varric
he's gonna i'm the same way i always
just stay as the main character
i'm gonna go throw caltrops down next
time and then run away
eric's pretty cool
see he's faster
he
yeah he does feel like he's moving a
little quicker
oh
not going to be anyone over here there's
going to be some elf root
yep nice just gonna grab some elf root
but again like this since this is the
intro part it's not as open and
freewheeling as the later parts that we
will arrive at yeah all of this is
actually the pre-title
section yeah like when i got to the
point where it was like dragon age
inquisition
i had already been playing for like two
hours it's like a serious title card
yeah
uh i don't think caltrops are gonna
affect this guy but i'm gonna throw them
down anyways with a little power shot
from bianca
uh so
i tap a like so this is the drawback
like i
did that dude just disrupt the rifts did
you
no so like disrupting a rift is not
because it has to be caras who does it
freaky dudes
cool
i never saw those guys these look like
real tall skinny ones they're totally
messed up they're freaky i don't like
them
uh so
disrupting the rift is something that
only uh
our buddy here can do all right but now
we can close it
disrupting again just like
sends out like a burst damage that kind
of stuns any demon uh it disrupts them
basically so it's a really good thing to
do during combat but it takes a second
for you to like charge up and like
shoot your hand beam at it and if you
get hit during that it interrupts your
disruption stops channeling
thank the maker you finally arrived lady
cassandra
i don't think we could have held out
much longer
and not just cassandra cross
hello
no time for talk i'm pissed off all the
time
and quickly
i like how when when i choose the most
aggressive way to say it possible then
it kind of like mitigates it for me it's
not it's never as aggressive as you're
taking it because then all the other the
other characters would hate you and they
can't you know
they can't quite write that in it's
never anna process robinson level of
aggression
someone was asking uh i didn't i don't
remember who someone was asking about
building
a home in this game
and i don't know if you can oh
affinati says you cannot
but you can have like a main base and
you can decorate and upgrade it
yeah you have you have sort of a home
base and that's where you you're like
i don't can you decorate it with stuff i
don't know i never got to that point
yeah uh you there is some progression
stuff where you like sort of build your
war council and get a bunch of different
get more assets in the field and like
increase your power in some interesting
ways which we'll get into in a little
bit um
but
i don't think you have a house
that you can like decorate the herald of
andraste needs no home
no
for the world
is not its home to begin with
he is of another place oh
getting close to the big rift just a
little little jog
climb up the hill
jump away down there
ouch
it's fine
don't worry about it this place got
blown
they up a woman was in the rift behind
you
no one knows who she was
it's a mystery
and we apparently don't remember any of
it either nope it's all a mystery oh so
sad burnt people yeah this is like a
like a pompeii type situation ooh yucky
where these people were like frozen
in the blast oh there's a there's a
gnarly one oh not so good screaming in
agony
forever
it's rough man this this place is
a bad scene
let's go run in there
oh wait hold on
loot
sorry you're dead but i'm going to take
your stuff give me that scout helmet
who should put on a scout helmet nah
forget it
we'll deal with your inventories later
for now oh sad look at you sad burnt
person oh god that hurts
it's really going to show us these burnt
people
just in case you missed them coming in
there are some real burn people
oh look at that smoldery look he gave
we really did succeed in making a very
handsome canary by the way
yep
that's the big rift
or i guess breach is what they call the
big rift the breach rifts are like the
mini breaches
and then there's like a big main breach
outside of this breach isn't there too
or are there multiple breaches all over
the land right
not
100 i wonder what happened to cassandra
she has that big scar right here she
does she's a she's a warrior you know
she's done the war
are you ready
hmm
just telling me what to do doesn't
really seem like something you could say
can i even get up there
i'm not sure how to even start getting
up to that thing
no
this riff was first
so this was really funny because it told
me to find a way down and i was like
okay i'll probably have to find this
path
so i like went back out of the temple
and ran around i realized you just need
to jump over that wall oh really just
jump over that wall you can you can walk
around that way i think but
there's a way down found it
uh so there's like some weird if you if
you walk around you like hear this weird
uh
voice like
talking about prepare the sacrifice
yeah
i'm gonna hear a little more of it now i
think
well it doesn't hurt this time
what's going on
that was your voice
most holy called out to you but
weird things happen at the breach
we have an intruder
flame eye shadow man you can't trust
those dudes you were there
who attacked and the divine mischief
was this vision true
what are we seeing
i don't remember
echoes of what happened here
the fade bleeds
don't worry we'll shut it down but it is
close
albeit temporarily i believe that with
the mark the rift can be opened and then
sealed properly and safely
however opening the rift will likely
attract attack soulless man this guy's
got knowledge
he knows what he's talking about
a little suspicious here
i mean i guess
you never know who can't afford to be
too careful
this guy's got our back
oh it's happening
hit it with the
what's the name of the ghostbusters gun
particle stream ion blaster ooh
this guy's bad news
shoot it with tiny arrows
it would become enraged all right let's
just hold on a second everybody uh
tactical camera i want to see what this
guy looks like yep right about crotch
level here so we got a good look at his
demon crotch
uh lots of green stuff coming out you
can't really um yeah you can like
sort of controlling
how far you zoom in and out oh yeah all
right
this is the rift so i'm going to try to
disrupt that thing this is a pride demon
i like how the demons in a lot of the
demons and dragons but this reminds me
how they're named after like cardinal
sins and stuff
oh look at this guy's face yeah the eyes
are really cool oh
yeah
too many eyes
too much pride too many horns dibs on
the horns
oh yeah maybe we can glue them onto our
horn stubs i don't know would that be
too pathetic i'm not sure
i don't know the norms of qunari culture
yeah is is that would that just be
ghastly like no guys it's cool i got
demon horns now it's fine
uh every everything's okay
maybe they're even better it's like a
trophy
all right we should probably start
fighting this thing
so when i did it and you should tell me
how you did it because my
strategy was i just hung out back here
and shot it for a long time oh really
yeah while these guys mixed it up
because the the first couple times i
played it i didn't even realize i had to
be disrupting the rift at the same time
i just tried to kill the demon i was
like wtf this game's so strong it's like
the first boss how come and then i
realized i had to be going in and
disrupting the rift like can i even
okay so i think i chose interacts for
this let's so let's see will he now
start disrupting the rift
no
no he just like ran directly under there
yeah that was my problem like what are
you doing right now buddy go just drop
the rift okay
there you go
so it's gonna give you tactical feedback
so now see it's not like it's armor is
down yeah
i'm not gonna clobber it in the butt
with a smash-o-strike
mighty blow putting putting it in the
corner tactic would work really well
i managed to get it in a corner one time
oh really and it was great hacked at it
how's everybody doing everyone's doing
okay
all right i can disrupt the rift now so
this is another good thing to do uh-oh
solas has low health
he took a health potion good work i like
that lightning width i hate that
lightning whip i died that a couple
times oh really oh what there's a whole
bunch of jerks here now oh i'm gonna
taunt them ha ha
you guys are jerks and you smell like
butt
are you gonna strike at me i wanna do
the payback strike oh yeah eat it ow
go revive yourself okay yep fair can you
revive
people while this he's chasing the mage
okay let's uh
let's switch to varric
varric you are going to run over here
and revive me
i don't think you can assign revive
all right so now i'm just going to go
back
and be so less like running away
oh
that's the big backhand coming down
you can see it doesn't look good run
away oh you missed me
nice nerd
oh yeah you missed me again
why is that how long has it taken you to
revive that dude
eric what the hell
what the hell he's not reviving him
what are you wasting your time doing
revive
see you went away there we go all right
he went back he's i told him to revive
he's gonna do it oh
he's not doing it i'm gonna have to i'm
gonna have to take charge here yeah
loop around did i just walk right by him
crap
eric you blew it
i'm very disappointed in you where's
cassandra double revive
i was gonna say the demons left you very
much alone while you were doing that
that's nice yep all right we need to
disrupt this thing real quick
we've got too much armor now quick hit
this disrupt oh no ah
took it on the chin all right now we're
going to really get it going here
disrupt
nailed it
smash attack
smash was ahab
chop chop chop chop to chop chopping up
right demon in the butt
oh no that looks like it hurt whoever
you just did that too and i disrupted
the thing yet
i don't think so because you can still
pretty disrupt oh no he's back there you
go back to
full on armored up
all right hold on let me get one of
these real quick
oh you're glad you guys are around i
don't i don't
attack him oh my
cool down thing was not up ow
i see what you mean about that lightning
thing
not cool not very fun
need to disrupt the rift disrupt it
don't you laugh at me pride demon i'll
take you down
what i did is i just assigned everyone
with the tactical camera to defend the
qunari
and just use the qunari so they just
followed me around and defended me
whatever i was doing
but
did that work
it worked but it was it was kind of
clumsy because they just ended up being
like right under the demon the whole
time and kind of getting clobbered like
that
but it didn't it worked oh man he's so
close oh my health is so low give me one
of them potions steal him
you have this much fade rift left oh
clobber
just wrapped up oh i'm shutting it down
oh yeah
that's that's how handsome we look right
now
i don't have much oh it takes a lot of
energy to even pretend to do this
oh
up top
done
done and done boom what you think about
that
people who put me in jail
no i just saved you
but that's not all
there's lifts everywhere what
i thought i totally conquered the game
no
yep that was the end of the game nice
playing with you chris nailed it done
90 minutes of content
30 of which are character creation
i mean if you just made a character
creation game i might play it anyway
look our horns what
i don't understand what's going on
they're toying with my emotions maybe
like they said that we had to prove
ourselves worthy you come in later
yeah oh man
i can only hope let's keep our fingers
crossed
what's up kid
i swear
let's be nice to this person only we
only care about this person fine i'm in
a good mood because my horns are back
yeah i'm not sure if it's going to last
don't worry about it
it's cool kid
whoa
i am but a humble servant
you're back in haven
the breach stopped growing just like the
mark on your hand
let's take a look
wow sans are big
it's all anyone has talked about for the
last three days
what do you think then we're safe
everything's cool
she said at once
and where is she
in the chantry
so nervous it makes a lot more sense how
nervous this kid is yeah when it's a
giant kunari as opposed to like my like
live elf lady
we have arms
oh yeah
uh that's excellent we earned them oh
man now we can like take time to
appreciate art and stuff yeah what's up
unhappy lady
yeah posing for a portrait probably was
a pain in the butt i'm gonna read this
letter real quick
you know actually yesterday
i walked up to a minstrel and listened
to them play a song and i got an
achievement patron of the arts oh really
so maybe if you stare at a painting long
enough
get it similar get an achievement yeah
i'll look in this box that this kid left
what'd you bring me kid
a dawn lotus a rare herb give me that
rare herb
oh should i can you play the song of joy
no i can't play it i'm sad i can't try
it i'm so happy i must leap
all right now this is one of those times
where you need to do the slow walk
because outside your door is like a hell
of people and they're just standing
there waiting for you to walk by and i'm
like
that's right i got horns
that's right y'all just toss your head i
don't know where they were but let's
never speak of that again
as you can see thank you thank you
magnificent thank you all for coming out
here much appreciated uh miss i'm over
here i'm sorry excuse me if you were
wanting to look on my majesty it's it's
right here hello yes
okay yep now you've recognized me cool
i'll just continue onward
androstek herself was looking after us
don't worry i feel quite healthy well
watch me jog up these steps
i didn't even break a sweat
yep
yep yep oh more kneeling people yes
don't mind if i do parade by you
majestically
they were kneeling in wait for you oh
yeah now that little kid ran out through
the whole village and was like he's up
he's up everybody's assumed the people
quick bow jen you flicked you might walk
by that's right close the bridge
no biggie
just got a big magic hand here
also dope horns maybe maybe you want to
check them out no horns what's this
someone left something on the wall
proclaiming of my greatness
nope that's just a story i don't like to
read stories unless they're about me
does it have horns no
not interested hello people would i
would like to go among these people
guards guards can i guards excuse me i
am the herald of andreas they are
waiting they've been waiting to see me
it's
all right i'll do signings later sorry
just i i don't have time for it outside
the castle
gotta go see
lady c
oh god i think i'm gonna be sick
oh no i can't get in there okay it's
fine it's fine i'm cool i'm cool
you really are a fan of the slow watch i
am because it's like yeah you're getting
all of the glory
gotta know talk about a second life in
video games
yes
check it out hello
yes i ha i all right i've arrived here
oh look chantry people
sister
wow
doors just fly open for me
you've made this very simple question
okay
momentous no one's watching now we can
we can run we can hurry up
i wish you could do the thing
the like splinter cell thing where you
like double tap a to kick open the door
did someone say my name it's karas
do you see my horns i have them now
i totally have them now
thank you to the person in chat or
people who said that we would have them
later yeah i thought you were just
toying with our emotions
we were very fragile at that time it was
a dark time in our lives it was and you
helped us get through
thank you
uh you want my help again
you need my help
you have done
are we still sassy though now that we
have horns oh i don't know maybe we're
super nice maybe maybe it's just like
rebalanced our hormones you know what
you're right because the only reason we
were mean is because we had nub horns
but now that we have beautiful horns we
should be kind okay yeah i think that
would be consistent with karos's
character it would at least maybe thaw
off a little bit maybe like middle
response okay okay maybe not top
response it does that bioware thing
where like
top tends to be pretty positive the
second or like
warmer or friendlier and the bottom or
sort of tends to be a little more
brusque
and then middle
is
middle
i thought he said that thing on his head
and i was going to be like the horns
they were talking about
i'm sorry did you say horns oh hen oh
yeah yeah that green blowing thing yeah
i'm not a chosen one what more do you
want
are you serious oh there's special
emotions with each of them
are you sure yeah so what do we want
thumbs up
confused brain
burly man
fist of rage
or
hmm
i mean i think looking for information
fits our newfound calm
but what what more do you want is that
or is that confusing one i don't know
which one
oh i don't know
i feel like what more do you want is a
good middle
more do you want from ground
oh that was still kind of brisk
that was pretty breast cancer
cassandra will start being nice to you
thought off immediately right it's like
it's blossoming in our heart but it
hasn't yet uh fully changed because you
know we still remember what it was like
to not have horns i know that's true
yeah yeah the hurt is still there
i really wanted to know because i kind
of missed this last time like what the
inquisition is actually looking for
because i was fighting for them but i
wasn't i needed her to explain it again
here it is
we have no leader
no numbers
so this is the part where like i like to
investigate and sort of learn about the
inquisition of old and the holy war and
stuff like that i feel like for the sake
of the stream we should just proceed to
pace all right
do i want to help or is it rather
strange or do i agree for now i want to
help now because we feel bad that we
were so brushed to cassandra
now she cut she slightly approves of us
she's like yeah
okay that was a good answer
sort of
awkward handshake offering
they're like uh let's not animate the
handshake let's put that below frame
you've seen the size of his hands
for life
i'm so excited that the horns came back
is this a montage we're gonna have a
montage that's the war council a montage
we'll meet those two later we need to
get to our ltc
late title card
oh
that abbreviation makes you sound so
cool
send the ravens
oh that made me miss raven
oh raven
loveliest female dwarf taylor swift
pig nose
one raven goes to this fortress which
people might recognize as a place that
is there i don't know what it is
one goes that also looks like the
coastal place
with
oh we're gonna get like a our martin
luther moment here
yeah nailed to the church wall i mean
it's not a church it's a fort
inquisition
stuff
we will inquisit
you
get ready to get inquisitated
i'm worried about this i don't like it
that dude's pissed
i do like it i'm cassandra it's a
business time hear me train warriors
train
this all looks good thank you very good
very good yes
ship shape
she's reviewing the troops yes damn
she's badass i know right
she's touring the facility and picking
up slack
oh where'd i get this dope cloak wow
i've been wearing that the whole time
look how dope we look no we definitely
haven't
that's
dude he is resplendent
couldn't have said it better isn't the
blonde hair was a nice touch it was i
agree
so what game have we been playing
oh yes that's right it's dragon age
inquisition
yeah
so now you can start playing the game no
now we can like get into it for real uh
so this is the part where you kind of uh
you scurry about and you can talk to
like the smith the quartermaster the
alchemists
i'm not sure
if i like actually need to do that stuff
basically i think you just find out that
you can you know bring them stuff to
forge things so i guess we can skip it
yeah i wonder if they like give us
like you can't unlock than other kind of
potion unless you go to the alchemist
uh maybe i'll just run around here real
quick like this is the quartermaster
hello friend uh so there's
requisitions we're basically gonna
figure out what requisitions are about
i'm not a mercenary i'm the chosen one
i am him i'm the herald of andraste
you and your chest hair both most people
would have spread that out over more
than one day that's fine
this is all [ __ ]
he might like that he likes he's the
only character in the game that has said
a cuss word so far all right
none of this [ __ ] should have happened
yeah seeing your proves i knew it half
of it
for days now i get you there
watching demons and maker knows what
fall out of it
bad for morale would be an
understatement
i still can't believe anyone was in
there that coat is just glorious
incredible i never want to wear any
other armor
yeah
i'm still not sure i believe that any of
this is really happening
if this is all just the maker winding us
up i hope there's a damn good punch line
coming
you might want to consider running at
the first opportunity i've written
enough tragedies to recognize where this
is going
heroes are everywhere i've seen that
but the hole in the sky that's beyond
heroes
we're going to need a miracle
maybe that miracle is us and my [ __ ]
the rift behind you keep setting up
these awesome like photographic displays
i love it
alright that's a place i can buy stuff
smith is right outside the doors open i
say
you will know him by his frequent
jumping
and his glorious horns
what's up
armor modification cool cool cool no
defender coat that's what it's called
everyone be cool i pulled out my sword
just to show it to you isn't it cool all
right it's a way now i was wondering how
the sword is attaching to his back do
you think it's a super strong magnet
i mean yeah it's woven throughout this
cloak yeah
i think his cloak is magnetic
how long this thing how's the new gear
fit
odd art it's not exactly what i'm used
to
wrong time for style to dictate what you
wear wow
i mean this is pretty startling blades
but we're not fighting bandits
my gear will see you through demons
apostates whatever this world i was just
trying to take it down so you'll keep
making the awesome looking stuff
something special
you bring the material cool you're the
guy
got it
check you later goodbye goodbye
i like how epically he says goodbye so
well
goodbye goodbye he's kind of got a bit
of like what to him i feel like a little
bit of that uh
fling on majesty yeah i see that for
sure
the apothecary is a beyond
path
that would be a sick cosplay
i invite any of you who are watching to
cosplay that
and tweet it to me this guy so i may
enjoy it yes
that would be incredible
this is not the right direction
i have reached a dead end
whoops where are you going chris waters
it's fine i'm just going to climb back
up into the city i'd like to do a little
parkour in my spare time parkour
park
you're really bad at parking
that's why i practice out behind this
rock where no one can see me
the chosen one of andraste cannot be
seen
looking like too parkour like a buffoon
he must excel in all he does
and be a shining example for those who
would follow the inquisition
it would be fun to design a character
after war
designer canary that looks like work
next time get like some forehead tattoo
or something going on
yeah you guys should uh send this before
losses hey buddy i'm not gonna chat
right now i gotta go talk to the
apothecary hello
oh dude someone's trolling us
super mega loser says i don't see any
horns what are you talking about no
they're right there i see them don't
they're shining in majestic
thank you you healed me and [ __ ] you're
a good dude
oh he healed us yeah this is the
apothecary well
you can pay me
just a little thing you can do to pay me
back i'm in charge of keeping our lives
fixed with potions i like this guy's
sense of humor i do not like his beard
initially it looks like a portrait
behind him
it's creeping on him
oh i gotta get out of here man yeah that
dude your apothecary art is creeping me
out
all right
so
i want a regeneration potion
equipped here
yep that's the one
great i need l fruit to make it but i
think i have to add you have some
fruit
or you had maybe varric has
do you share you share all of your
inventory right yeah no once you've
equipped the it to yourself
uh
you have it for realsies
upgrade potions yeah i can't do any of
this stuff right now let's get out of
here go go go go go
okay
time to go report
to the chantry in the chrome's room
cassandra
what's up
chantry and talk to john chantry
and while we do this i'm actually going
to take a quick break i'll be back in
just a moment sweet
shall i talk to the chantry yes without
you oh yeah
there you go
thanks
does it trouble you
ooh
i don't know what she's talking about
does what trouble me my horns no they
don't trouble me they're fantastic i
think she's probably talking about the
mark on my hand
um it's fine
it's fine i'm tough
next time
what's important is that your mark is
now stable
as is the breach
you've given us time and so lust
believes the second attempt might
succeed provided the mark has more power
the same level of power used to open the
breach in the first place
that is not easy to come by
sounds like fun am i making fun of her
if i say that
i think i want to i like i like sandra i
want to flirt with her as much as
possible something in mind you have
something in mind because you're so
smart and powerful cassandra
i think you can flirt in this game
i think i read that may i present
commander cullen
leader of the inquisition
forces such as they are they said colin
collins soldiers in the valley and i
feel what a nice caller you have cohen
this is lady josephine montelier our
ambassador and chief diplomat ooh
josephine even taller than i'd heard
and of course you know sister leliana
my position here involves a degree of
she is our spymaster
yes
factfully put cassandra
hmm
yes i'm impressed by you all an
impressive bunch of titles
i mentioned that your mark needs more
power to close the breach for good i
really know so much about my mark the
rebel mages for help
and i still disagree the tempers could
serve just as well
we need power commander enough magic
poured into that mark
might destroy us all
templars could suppress the breach
weaken it so
pure speculation i was a templar
i know what they're capable of
unfortunately neither group will even
speak to us yet
the chantry has denounced the
inquisition and you specifically
wow so
neither the mages or the chantry want to
help us
it doesn't matter let's fight look how
gloriously golden i am
some are calling you
the remaining clerics have declared it
blasphemy and we heretics for harboring
you
chancellor roderick's doing no doubt
it limits our options approaching the
majors all templars for help is
currently out of the question you guys
like cassandra too
i like her a lot
um so the herald of andraste i would ask
about that but
basically they're just going to tell me
that i
have been seen with this woman and the
most holy and
i might be the savior of the world
um
they aren't more concerned about the
breach the real threat
i'm on board i want to show them i'm
super on board stop it
the chantry is telling everyone you'll
make it worse
there is something you can do there is a
lot of dialogue but i like that by the
name of mother giselle has asked to
speak to you yeah this is xbox one
everyone asking and knows those involved
far better than i
her assistance could be invaluable
i will talk to her i'll see what she has
to say
you will find mother giselle tending to
the wounded in the hinterlands
look for other opportunities to expand
the inquisition's influence while you're
there
we need agents to extend our so i'm like
the pr
rep for the inquisition as well as the
chosen one
a lot of responsibility to put on one
person i won't leave this all to the
herald see cassandra always looking out
for me
i won't leave it all to you i'm gonna
try and help
all right so we're going to the
hinterlands
we're in ferelden
let's go to
the hinterlands
ray
and we have to use secrets because we
don't have any other
way of using
our resources yet
oh no
speaking of freckles those are awesome
freckles
yeah no fight yet sorry
we still have some talking to do
there's a raven again
looks like there's mother giselle
tending to the wounded
i think
oh so we unlocked the area so we we did
the scouting now we know what's in the
hinterlands now i can go there check it
out
and i can talk to mother giselle
and i want everyone
in my party
especially cassandra
especially
i like lyanna too i wish i could take
her
combo breaker you don't like liliana's
story
i do actually i don't know much about
her story i actually just
i like her outfit
so i think this is where our quest
really starts because we're kind of
trying to gather
support for the inquisition
so i have to
talk to everyone and make them believe
that i'm the herald or at least that i
can stop the breach
which of course i can do because i have
glorious horns and a fantastic look
and you know
super buff
so many things to load
how are you guys doing in chat be sure
to stay in touch with me let me know if
there's anything you want me to do in
particular
we know what you did at the breach
they might not know much about the
qunari but is she a dwarf she must be
because she's pretty short it's a
promise it's like half my height harding
at your service
i will all of us here will do whatever
we can to help that's harding huh
ever been to kirkwall's high town
i can't say i have why
you'd be harding and
no
never mind
hello hello how was your break oh
refreshing i ate a banana nice
uh oh i want to i want to hear the
stories you've heard about me
we're looking for um
gisele mother giselle
i think that was [ __ ] yeah great
hope
and we're trying to be the the world's
best pr agent for the
inquisition oh yeah we gotta we gotta
shape public opinion we gotta control
the message right the inquisition do you
want the controller back no good okay
and people always said that talking to
this dwarf i think she's a dwarf she's
very tiny she's really short but with
the mage templar fighting getting worse
yes yes all the strife i'm gonna fix it
all yes yes
did
we should go find him i haven't done
that yet i'm curious our men are doing
what they can to help protect the people
but we also have to find mother lady
yep nobody can hold up very long without
me yes yes yes i'm i'm glorious yeah
she's already on message
yeah you got it
all right so
uh let's go to the
potions table because i think we need to
assign is this a potion stable no see
this is this is about where i got in the
game so you're going to have to direct
me or you can take the controller back
here's my camp
inspect the requisitions yes this is
like
oh well we got it here
oh we gotta talk
that's sweet take a quick nap traveling
takes it out of me so equipping potions
like we have the this one equipped
uh actually we don't have enough elf
roots so i'm just gonna
equip these for us but like
these guys don't have
it equipped i think we can equip them
with it i don't know what the point of
this is because we won't be able to make
it unless we come back here but just to
make sure everyone has that potion on
hand in their slot i see uh also you'll
notice that there's like little arrows
above all of us cause i think we all
leveled up
ooh
so we can go to character record
and like give us some new stuff to do
like uh what did we level up on this guy
last time uh we gave him the like the
block right right right the parry kite
yeah yeah are you gonna keep going down
that tree you think
uh
i don't know the guard this uh
so the next one these aren't active
abilities they're passive they just give
you a little extra strength so this is
each critical hit reduces the cooldown
times on your abilities or your critical
hits crack armor and run shields
that's kind of nice because i bet we're
going to run into some armor soon
let's do it
apply and then i think
so
for these guys this is soul us now and
you can like you have ai tactics and you
can like sort of set their behaviors
which is real deep stuff that we're
gonna well not that's not that deep it's
actually pretty easy because it you sort
of uh
you know
tell them to prioritize when do you do a
healing potion you know how much
do you keep in reserve just in case like
can you make everybody focus on one
character like focus on healing them and
stuff like that
or is it just in general like when your
party gets it looks like it's only these
four um yeah so targeting behavior
it will defend the controlled character
follow the controlled character or
defend
so all right this is the quest map
we're gonna try to
where's the horse guy he's over here
we're gonna try to make our way over
there i think
um
although we should hit up some
camps along the way
but meanwhile back in the two points to
spend for solas the mage
he already has one in like winter so
what should we make him just like a
super ice mage guy yeah i like that all
right
keep it cold
what else you got what's this you raise
a wall of ice to keep enemies at bay i
think we can get that one
by standing still you enter a meditative
state that restores your mana
your barrier explodes into wild magic
exploding into wild magic and always
oh can't unlock it do i have to get both
of these
oh no this one doesn't have a line that
goes
on unlearn that so no we have to learn
this and then we can learn wall advice
or
ice mine
i like wall advice that sounds yeah that
sounds really gonna go for that
uh apply those
now let's go to cassandra
she's a weapon and shield kind of
warrior
and so we can sort of she's got the
shield wall we can increase the
effectiveness of that
uh
this payback strike ooh that sounds fun
yeah it does which she already has
we can like increase the effectiveness
of that
lunge and slash i feel like she would a
shield bash let's go for a shield bash
how about that i'm into that
bear mauls the wolves i like to choose
this one just because the name is dope
as hell i would absolutely institute it
because of the name bear mauls the
wolves and shield bash
let's apply those she'll have a little
bit more to work with and then finally
varric
who's an archer
and he also has some like he has like
these poison caltrops ability
so this is
poisoned weapons i love poison poison is
good all right we got pro poison
and then this is all of your poison
effects last longer
or we could double down on this one it's
just an extra damage bonus what do you
think
extra damage bonus for instance let's do
that once because then we'll open up
more of the tree this one yeah all right
i like that good call
boom everyone's level three
let's go out and whack some dudes on
their face that's how the sun is shining
off our beautiful armor oh yeah let's
get into this let's get into a god ray
here
no oh where is it
just dappled sunlight in the forest
yes you are majestic
uh so the requisitions thing you gotta
talk to the requisitions officer and
then they give you like
come here
tell me what do you want
you may want to look into this
uh so they want to make some prisoner
cages so we need to like gather a bunch
of iron and ferelden locks which is
basically just stuff you get by looting
people
uh so
when it happens so we're we're the
savior we're the pr agent we're the
hunter gatherer
everything falls on our shoulders
they're the total package
let's watch your steps sandra's the only
one who cares about us she said she
didn't want this all to fall to us she's
the only one we're flirting with
cassandra now by the way oh
i fully support that decision
deal on kill critical damage bonus let's
left this treasures test out in the
forest that's fine i don't know it seems
like a pretty pretty bad place to put
your treasure chest but
critical damage what are the what does
life drain do
two percent heal on kill i want to give
that to cassandra yeah
we'll take the critical damage one
cassandra i like it i'm going to put a
ring on it
and off we go
towards the giant arrows
well
wow
that did a little bit of damage not too
much
yeah
oh is that a dead person oh dag i'm
sorry you're dead loot them
nope i can't oh man they're not lootable
don't worry i mean i would if i could
what's the point of dead people if you
can't loot them
truly
they're trying to protect the refugees
oh look at you all locked in this ice
frozen thing all right
you're all gonna get chopped to bits
i'm gonna shout at you first
i just clobbered that dude on the ground
i want to see you smash someone into the
ground again
that was awesome boom
just like below the ground
all right where's next bad guy where you
at
oh they're all over there
onward
to battle
uh if anyone wants to see me play as
other
people
feel free
smack you both on the ground for free to
call out and chat it could play as
cassandra or solas the mage or var
uh maybe not varric the road because
we'll be playing as a rogue a little bit
later when we try
uh let me check out my other character
um but if you want to see some cassandra
action
oh no i thought that was from solas i
think that was an ice mine yeah because
solas has that ability but get clobbered
boom
well we just got a taste of what that
could be like
did we not pick yeah we didn't pick that
one we did ice wall instead
just stole his silk underwear
i'm gonna use it in crafting
i can use these
undies silk oh there's more bad guys
let me move at an incredible rate over
here
oh hell no yeah you guys you guys just
fight i gotta
tie my shoe real quick
wow make her take you indeed
shout
oh
oh
it sounds like
that's it is that his war cry yes wow
everyone's kind of like huh
yep
like who is this guy is he trolling us
bob the cat lol challenges you to a
dance-off not now bob the cat damn it
bob can't you see i'm busy he's busy
come on attack me
oh
yeah
we are victorious once more
we are victorious once more that's
that's true
eat it
i only got tiny blobs on my sword
cassandra's shield always gets a ton of
blood on it
and also her face and yeah the whole
situation your butt has some blood did
you sit on some but some blood maybe
when i was looting
you should wipe off your sword hello uh
please take off that helmet and look at
me
eyes cast downward lower than regulation
i just stared him down and then walked
away well it was a shot of the
inquisition thingy
i think
oh what's up mother giselle
mama g as i like to call her good old
mama g yeah how you doing girl
doing the lord's work yeah
the work of the maker mm-hmm
hush dear boy allow them to ease your
suffering
i don't want mages to heal me
i am
and you must be the one they are calling
how did you know by my glorious horns
yes it is me yes they are real
yes i've had them all along
there was never a time when i didn't
have these
uh you asked for them i'm the one you
asked for me
got to be nice
you're on board at least you need them
to think you're on board that's true
unless they give me one
look of
any kind of sass or mention the time
that shall not be mentioned
the pre-horn pre-horn yeah we don't
speak age
we don't speak of any ph times
pht is strictly off limits if anyone
mentions it they get the sword
or at least the angry fist dialogue yes
look at those
but horns not beyond the reason
go to them
convince the remaining clerics you are
no demon to be feared
i'm not a demon to be feared despite my
majestic horns give them something else
thanks dogs and cats says that we're
we're reviewing it for him and it's nice
nice it's nice uh
who wants to be dead will that work that
won't just make it worse
because you oh that close-up
some people find me frightening
let me put it this way
you needn't convince them
i mean because he's so handsome it's
understandable it's understandable to
get slightly intimidated by incredibly
beautiful qunari
look how nice mamaji is to us
thank you seems like a good thing to say
to mama g
or sent to help us but i hope
me too what we need now
the people will listen to your rallying
call as they will listen to no other
you say
she's like our pr guru
she's behind the scenes the mentor yeah
she's telling us how to she's the
consultant how to win hearts and minds
how to win friends and influence people
the mama g method
but i will do whatever i can
god that hat is so dope the square hat
yeah i understand why you want to wear
that hat because it makes you kind of
look like you have horns
which
i fully understand
is the dopest
looksie i like that emote that's a good
one we should speak with him
is there a horned emote
uh it's actually in control's hair but
it's shaped like horns
so well played
i claim this
uh place
for me you claimed it oh yeah i claimed
it
and then i parkoured my way up here
parkour of course gonna talk to this guy
pick up a quick quest he wants me to get
some meat
what's the problem people need food
what's your problem
i don't do we what's our policy on
killing rams
they are sort of our horned brethren but
also people need them to eat and also
the leather can be used to make things
for my party members
it's a tough one it is tough now that
you put it that way they are our
brethren
i'm helping the food situation by the
way right now are we sellouts though
because i think i've never i haven't
seen another qunari
in this entire so maybe we're just you
know maybe the herald has no race
what do you mean the herald uh speaks
for all people
and the hunger of the his subjects well
i guess they're not my subjects you know
yet the pr did not approve that word
so this is another quest to just like
find some stuff out in the hinterlands
and uh we're just gonna go adventure
onto the hinderlands and try to find
this horse master guy
the errand boy and the pr consultant and
the savior i mean people think being a
hero is all about just hitting things
with swords that's not true it's not the
case nope
gotta spread the good word look you have
a horn like a a horn horn
yeah
i do have so apparently you're not
against stealing horns from other people
that's
true
i wish there was just a blow that blast
that hip horn button that i could do all
the time
oh yeah are you looking for rams
uh i'm just going to go out into yawn
hills and
think about it see what happens
here we go i've actually never been this
way i've explored a bunch of the
hinterlands in my other game but it was
all like
down here mostly so i'm kind of excited
to head up this way actually we can
establish this new camp ooh
just gonna go up through this rock here
what a pretty hike oh look and like you
could go down that way there's all sorts
of ways to go
this is where like we're saying before
it really starts to open up
and you've got a lot of hinterland
it is like going on a hike
this is a lovely place to set up a camp
let's do it
it's right by the lake
you can
dip your toes
and rest
and take
grab some blood lotus for some reason
and take a quick shower
oh yeah
this is romantic this is going on the
calendar right here romantic we gotta i
mean that's one of the inquisition's
plan right is get get calendar shots
yeah you're the poster boy look how
shiny your armor looks now
i'm in a secret waterfall rendezvous
too bad cassandra's in here
oh yeah what's somebody
oh hey guys oh hey guys
yeah go team
totally wasn't just enjoying myself in
that waterfall
map to waterfall all right we got to
keep an eye out for
a bridge that's got those pillars
because this is like a little treasure
nice oh map can you climb that
oh why is there
oh what why do i want to climb there
what is happening there there's a dude
in the chair that's been nailed to the
tree
and people have shot it with arrows i
feel like this is some kind of execution
style something that is this is grody
why didn't i jump here this is the start
of a horror movie why did that happen to
this person look at his toes
let's go
all right we gotta get out of here this
is creeping me right out it's like this
beautiful vista and then like dead guy
in a chair nailed to a tree yeah that
was that was grim
never know in dragon age you never know
all right uh actually there's
a thing over here we can check out it's
also slightly gruesome but nowhere near
as gruesome as that are those tents that
you set up because yes
exactly that's part of our camp
give me some of this embryo yeah not
sure what that's for embryo
i haven't unlocked that potion yet but
it's like you know it fills the belly
uh so this is an ocular room it's a
skull that you look through
like a telescope and you try to find
these
magical shards
to light up in the area
and then you can go pick them up
when you're exploring
and then you take them to be
investigated by some dude that i haven't
i don't know
what that is all about cool
but it's a good thing to do all right
where are we going now
quest map
rift over there
this is another camp
yeah let's try to get over let's set up
camp over by the horse guy which
probably means going down this way i
love getting horses and games it's one
of my favorite things
can we actually get a horse i don't
think so
but actually i don't know you might be
able to yeah no i think you can because
uh kevin was playing the game for review
and he says it does the like red dead
redemption thing where the you whistle
and the horse just like comes from off
frame
and it's like oh hey i got a horse now
they'll just die sweet
all right is this like a path i can go
down cool i don't need to grab all this
blood lotus i don't even have a potion
unlocked if you get us a horse chris
waters
it will be counted a complete win for
the day by me i will tr i will do my
darndest
just head down here
there's a big battle going on over there
but
we're just gonna judo chop james says
there's all sorts of mounts in this game
but i don't know if i don't know judo
chop james how do i know that you're
credible
he says we can ride a moose because
canadians i think you're trolling me and
i
i kind of appreciate it and i kind of
don't i really like the idea of being
able to ride a moose that would be
amazing actually i do appreciate it
because now that made me think of this
guy riding a moose which would look
awesome the amount of horns oh my
goodness that would be incredible
i found a templar encampment
spread the good word cool templars join
us clobber a templar over the head join
our cause oh what's up jerks
bring it on
ow
stop try that again oh you turn into ice
i'm gonna smack you on your
butt
get clobbered
i think you're big
take a swing oh you're attacking
cassandra i'm just gonna
clobber you all day all my health is low
yeah posh i feel like i need to go deal
with this archer situation yeah you guys
are not helping
whoa
right
so that gave me a quick barrier cara
smash
that archer's poisoned thanks to
i wonder if i can like if an archer
shoots me can i do the parry can i do
the parry oh no i have deaded died
revive
the
herald of andraste
all right now let's just do some barrack
shooting
all right everything's cool
that was a close one what do these guys
got what you got on what you got what
you got lamb's wool
nice
lambswool seems a little bit more uh i
mean it probably gets cold here at night
that seems pretty i would imagine that
to be true
for sure
thrusting long swords long sword
well
that seems very that that's for the
varric so varex is an accomplished
author right
i think part of our pr campaign needs to
be
romance novels starring me us the herald
of andraste uh-huh and i think a
thrusting longsword should factor in
absolutely
seems like a very powerful weapon oh
check it out oh is that the bridge it's
the bridge
all right so that's like discovering
landmarks but the bridge
all right let's look at the map i think
it said to go
and that's in the
inventory it said like nothing left
it's in the
codex
maps
yeah left go off to the left like up the
up the river probably
is that the yeah that's the one for sure
all if there's a bunch of jerks there's
a path
your jerks are gonna get it
you're not the only ones who can shout
go ahead
who are you even swinging at right now
bro oh no
we have an ability pool slapper says we
have an ability point to spend
damn we gonna spend it after this battle
get clobbered
club
i'm just
the other guy does not seem to be doing
effective battle although i guess
cassandra's one-on-one dude maybe that's
why your health is so low
crap well these guys aren't melee
feel like i need to help them out not by
doing that
oh he's dead he's dead quick
to cassandra's aid
don't worry cassie what's up jerk
she must did she drink a potion can they
do that on their own yes they like they
are set to drink it i think at like 30
percent
come on
counter attack oh i almost knocked him
off the cliff
sucka wanna do it again wanna take
another shot oh you're frozen you're not
doing anything
mega smash
get off of here you just go away and you
die
there was some loot on the ground over
there if you want it to your left there
you go right there give me the loop
i want to loot so ferelden lock that's
one of the things we need for our
good thing we found it inquisition thing
all right
don't worry i haven't forgot about the
ability point
oh i'm also going to check out this
intense deathroot vitar although i think
it's a
level 4 only
yeah it's red which means it's
level four i'm only level three
but since i'm level three wait i don't
have an ability point to spend
you've misled me horribly
alas
okay so yeah but you can also auto level
up like before you saw that we were
choosing the other guys character traits
you can auto level up if you don't feel
like doing that if you just want to
slash yeah all right where is this
waterfall
i think i see it in the distance
the three-pronged waterfall that we saw
on our map
discovered
oh this is the templar encampment
man the templars have secured the
position ahead don't worry we can
unsecure it baby do i need a potion i
feel like my health is low
wait
all right
yes everyone's health is low everyone
take a healing potion
i feel like a templar camp is ambitious
nah we can do it look at these horns i'm
nothing if not ambitious
you can do it
nice go ahead frozen
nice bam
i like how i clobbered that dude off a
cliff
using cover this is great
you are going to get
knocked on your smash oh okay it's
giving me the potion message
smash head
thanks barrick oh got that poison shot
dude
that's another dude quick
oh he's dead loot
what else awaits us deeper within the
templar camp i bet there's some more
dudes with you cheesy
so we're not we're not quite in all the
way so far so far celebrate success so
far so good come on are we ready for the
next wave because it's ready for us
ready for the next one
oh yeah get clobbered
come on team where's the rest of our
team
whoa that one was extra big oh it was
it was like a pedestal to your desk
i really like this oh that ability yeah
cassandra really clobbered those guys
i find myself missing with sword strikes
way more than i was missing with arrow
strikes
i did that too with my daggers
oh
she said dead a little too late i did
the extra clobbering stroke
dad give me the loot
sledgehammer oh do you want to see how
that compares we maybe should rock a
sledgehammer sure why not
i wanna be sledgehammer
royal elfrude sure
sure why not
all right any other weapons you were all
worried about
that's why you know your encouragement
really helped you need the heart of a
warrior chris waters that's true you
will learn you can learn from
ross
and his glorious horns oh look at that
much heavier damage wow
that's going to be awesome it's hammer
in time fosho
uh also we have
a new
this is cassandra
have a new shield what's her shield
oh this one reinforced let's go with
that let's go with the reinforced shield
also she has
a raider great sword is this two-handed
this doesn't appear to be
68 that seems like a big
switch seems like a no-brainer oh yeah
no that's a two-handed one
so she um she's i feel like we should
maybe build her shield yeah she's got
the shield bash she can't very well
shield bash without a shield nope
all right
that shield was nice the new one that we
gave her i think everyone else is pretty
well set
weapon wise
maybe we check armor real quick
we're fine we're fine we're fine
oh look at that thing whoa
oh man
do not mess with this guy goodness very
huge
warhammers are like the most disgusting
weapons ever
i'm just going to bash you like i'm
going to smash your body
with this with this giant hammer yeah
boom like you are as a nail is
look at this he's on the ground i'm just
bashing away at him with a freaking
hammer oh
counter ouchie but gouchey get it
going oh oh
and you're cooking fire it's so brutal
it fits him the weapon fits in it does
oh man
wow oh wow oh
oh man
and one to grow on
just in case you aren't flat
this is like
man you just gotta found it
i don't know what is this sweetish
finger sweetish
uh i mean it looks really cool all right
we got to check it out it's purple also
which is like
look at that giant hammer that thing is
so mean i feel like even if i have a way
cooler sword now
it's a tough decision we only had one
fight with the hammer but that sword
does look really awesome
all right i think i might have a
different uh vitar i can equip
uh let's oh wait no hold on first things
first
i leveled up
let's get another two-handed ability
uh wait should we decide whether you're
gonna use the sword or not i guess it
won't matter either way yeah
whirlwind is something we definitely
want to be able to do
yes absolutely approved
approved unanimous
unanimous
uh voting the world can we just get it
look at that in action unanimous
whoa
yes i love that
gotta have the whirlwind all right so
yeah i thought you said uh
i wetia i thought you said swedish
finger and that's what i thought you
said too like
i don't mind calling out the swedish the
swedish
sweden exists in the thetas that's weird
oh it's less dps it's less dps it's a
lot of these cool things uh
all right
uh that's pretty dope but it's also
i don't know
i mean just because it has purple on it
and just because it says it's rare and
special doesn't mean
that it's the coolest necessarily oh all
right time to put on whoa intense death
route okay so this is the thing that i'm
learning about vitars that i didn't
really know before
they're face paints right so this is
this is poison face prank that a qunari
is not you know
gonna take part into the flesh more
constitution and provides other
protections this is a better critical
damage or we have two right keep keep we
have
but look at sorry look at the face
though that
like do you see the face paint now like
can we handle this this level of face
painting whoa
it's like kiss
it is that is so it's like real intense
glam rock vitar
i think it kind of fits with our new
sword or with our new hammer ruining our
effect but it actually fits very well
this is my battle face yeah look at that
lipstick
oh wow i will kiss you with my poison
face paint
because it hardens my flesh and provides
other benefits
i approve of this strange phase you're
going through caras
i don't i'm trying to find more
self-confidence he is
all right so we're we're around oh
thanks i want to get this iron though
i'm just going to yank it out of the
wall uh royal viper says drag h drag it
yeah
look at that beauty
screenshot that
oh that is all right that's pretty boss
all right where where is the
this iron
i like that they mine by just yanking
the iron out of the wall it's like i'm
having that i'm qunari i don't need so
much iron over here
yes i'm gonna obsessively gather iron
you guys
with iron you can it's important forge
things uh but there's also you know the
uh
the treasure thing we gotta find so you
can do once you're around sort of
secrets
uh you click the stick to do this kind
of ping
and then some it like this doesn't get
revealed until you actually
have the pain and have the map and so
iron bark is a
masterwork crafting material
we haven't done any crafting yet right
correct that would have to be back at
haven
you guys want to go for a swing
oh it's really shallow oh my gosh wow
just
you really okay i used to be a lifeguard
and i can tell you that
diving into water that you have not
checked the depth of super dangerous
probably not the best idea no definitely
not
you guys maybe don't want to do that i
can only tell you that because of my
lifeguard training cause it's not like
it's coming
oh yeah wow
wow and i've got the green flashes this
is wow this is for my music
out okay
um
what would the title of his music video
be
rock
i don't have a really good metal yell i
keep trying
but i don't have one the thing about a
metal yell is if you do it on a live
stream with a microphone right next to
your
throat people's ears get hurt i won't do
it don't worry
it's very thoughtful
all right so this is the reason i'm
flashing is because i ate a i drank a
replenishing potion
and it replenishes you over time yeah so
it's like i get it i'm healthy now i
learned not to dive into shallow water
oh look at these hella dead people loot
oh i'm so sorry give me your stuff oh
gold jewelry
letter a small item found on a body
a letter found on a dead body
take it back take it back take it back
dreams won't stop until you take it back
to the western fortress they will never
stop lyrics to ourselves you will wake
up screaming and find notes
take it back take it back or i will draw
allies to do it for me
that was incredible
i can't believe wow
first we got the shots you know usually
you lead with the lyrics
of the song but first we got we got the
you know cinematography down right and
then a little bit of the rhythm
dance
this one isn't as good of a song no
dwarves aren't as good as writing lyrics
that was yeah that was a little more
pedantic you're going to find this like
framed at the hard rock cafe like
original lyrics to take it back by
canary
and people are going to sit by and be
like oh my gosh they're going to take
selfies with it they definitely are and
they're going to have their faces
painted yes like that with that it's
going to become iconic
it is wow you can see all of all that
features
oh what's up
oh you want a fight
can we have it as a pet instead i would
like to but it poisoned me and is
attacking all of my fellows they won't
poison you
oh it's a poison wolf oh because it
wants to get sick you're smashing the
puppy this is really brutal oh it's okay
it's a bad puppy it is they started it
listen these direwolves oh
get whirlwind
dude and your guitar for the band can be
shaped like a sledgehammer or it can be
that sledgehammer we'll just string it
i think
it's gotta be bianca right
he's get or is he bianca like the base
you're the singer that's right so it's a
mic your sledgehammer is a mic yes the
microphone stand is a sled is a war
hammer
yes
yes perfect
here we are at the farms
everything is peaceful
and deserted and now there are crows
to be in good repair let's go inside it
might have loot
i like to find loot perhaps some knock
knock anybody home
hello oh loot what do you know
oh they abandoned everything but they
did leave us this sturdy defender coat
schematic
it's like we're not going to leave you
with a coat but if you want to make a
coat what's that i don't know i saw this
somewhere else it's kind of decorative i
haven't tried smashing it yet so uh nope
definitely
don't need to smell someone put a shield
up just in case that artifact oh yeah no
he does that whenever you start
oh what's up fox
oh that was
wow that was i feel bad about that
i am so sorry i have brutality can you
even loot it can you even i don't think
i can
walk away slowly chris waters i don't
walk away i feel really bad
oh what's up my horned brethren hello
wow are they going
to get out of here these guys are going
to charge
they don't charge very fast but they
made it pretty clear they are your
horned brother like pat them
you can't kill those friends i won't hit
it do you want you want me to hit it
with a hammer i mean
not unless you can eat it
i don't know if i can eat it
this these appear to belong to some this
is like an actual oh there's the horses
this is the guy maybe we'll get one of
those oh there's a thingy the ocularity
yeah the skull
skullfish yes that's what it's called
check in with the horse master here
hey vitonic nice to see you question
mark
really sad about the fox
i know that i'm trying to forget about
it i immediately tried to freak out i
might let you guys see oh gosh it's one
of those those gut reactions in video
games where you're like i'm gonna murder
his rampage kill it oh oh no what have i
done who am i and what have i become
hold on
look at that makeup man oh yeah
yeah let's just get a real nice frame up
wow all right horn face
okay let's go inside
anybody home
hello hello hello
i'm going to walk into your bedroom now
is that okay with you
hello i'm a giant warrior
please please horse please please base
horse master
did just call us a big brew your
inquisition
i just want a horse chris whatever you
have to do if you have to sledgehammer
him if you have to flirt with him okay i
just want a horse okay i can't just send
a hundred of the finest horses
yes you can come on
you probably can between here and haven
would be on them like flies on crap
david wow
once i know they won't end up as a cold
winter's breakfast what you need me to
murder some people
i think i got time for the shop fine
fine just tell me about should i ask me
if he has a problem with me or make it
personal
maybe maybe you could build a friendship
out of it
if you have a problem with me personally
i'd like to know yeah let's talk about
it that was a nicer way of putting
no idea how you ride without your feet
dragging on the ground
i am large yes
elena maybe she'll be reasonable
until then you deserve something better
than whatever knock-kneed plough they
gave you they didn't give me any i don't
even have a plow nag
a purebred for relatives where is it
where is it
where is it
where is it we're
okay okay okay is that over here that's
part of our mission
the stables are over there don't you
know a stable when you look at it chris
oh i definitely don't were you raised in
a city or something yes i was in the
suburbs oh this is a person's house
where's the horse house
is it over here
where the horses are
you silly silly city boy horse house
horse house
are you my horse yay
didn't even read what that said i just
want to get on the horse
to summon your mount press lb
oh my gosh we have a horse now oh yeah
runs look at the bounce all right here
you go ride the horse oh my goodness can
we jump things can we jump i bet you can
okay that way you could jump some stuff
we
oh that was kind of kind of sloppy
hey it's functional can we go faster
horsey
uh yeah try clicking the right stick
maybe
no no
i can jump but uh can i go oh there we
go there we go come on oh yeah yeah we
can even get
maybe if i run faster i can jump better
on run and
jump nope
oh god
okay okay okay okay
look i thought you were an accomplished
horseman
oh it's so good oh okay we're gonna run
straight towards that ready
and
jump ah his jumps are i'm okay ferelden
forder your jumps are a little bit
lacking but you are really pretty and i
love you and this is the best day of my
life there you go
thank you for letting me take it
up diddy yeah i missed that
i played d every week and my constant
struggle is just getting and keeping a
horse in d d it's like pretty much all i
want to do
keeps killing my horse oh brutal so this
is for you koibu you suck
second i got a horse
yeehaw all right get down off the horse
please
why why why would you get off the horse
listen i got to talk to these people
real quick so that i can get a million
horses for everyone to ride into battle
and be as epically awesome as me hello
old lady
i heard what my man said we need our
farmers back safe in their fields all
right since the breach appeared the
wolves have gone oh you have to kill the
wolves come after our men like beasts
with the water sickness the waters
it's a real lame name for a disease i'll
tell you that
there's like any number of words you
could make up for water sickness
awkward
different
c aqua itis
way better than water sickness
not very good but still way better than
the liquid
how we're talking
the blight they used in another game
too many men look at these apples
this farm is
prosperous
see you later i'll go smash some wolves
on the head oh hey guys did you see that
you know what it's you know what dnd is
like
what's up braun sellsword from game of
thrones
he's in this game wow he gets around
he's got a cameo
his agent is really good
cassandra cool i'm just having a
conversation
will you don't talk to him talk to me
what do you want me to do here
yes sure there are too many hills in
these parts good places for raiders and
bandits to gather i've marked good spots
on the map you set up watchtowers what
do i have like a lumber cart with me and
some craftsman yes i can do that no
problem of course i can i do everything
everyone in this world yes i can
definitely handle it do you have
anything that i can steal from you if i
saw that okay see you later in uh real
life i would also be kind of intimidated
true the makeup even more so
all right where are we going now we have
a horse i'm like completely satisfied
yeah this is pretty much it
uh all right what time is it how much
time we've left on this 12 39 so we have
an hour and 20 minutes okay we're gonna
horse around a little bit here
and
uh
and then at about uh
one o'clock so in about 20 minutes we
will switch over to
my other character we'll check out two
other areas they're not much further
than this so it's not any kind of
spoilers late game or anything like that
but just to give you guys a taste of
something different so for now
it's horse time did you see that really
awesome war horse in that picture yes i
did i hope we can get armor for a horse
i didn't even think of that until just
now yeah
i'm telling you that would be dope as
hell that equine lifestyle
i know it will all right let's go set up
a camp so i can basically call everyone
here and show off my horse yeah
oh i love this you just whistle and the
horse is there
booyah
whoa
see you guys later all my friends
disappear do they just disappear yeah
they're in your backpack they actually
it's actually like a voltron situation i
don't know if you can see it's like a
voltron thing like they are all the legs
and they form up into one giant horse
right yeah
away
uh all right
left stick okay while we're on the way
to set up a camp somewhere in the hills
um wait what's this exclamation point
here can i read from horseback aren't my
eyes that good look how look how
accomplished of a rider you are oh yeah
a prize-winning drufalo
drawful that's what those things are
called
see you guys later up you vanished into
darkness that was creepy as hell it just
like went into the horse's belly
uh while i'm on route to this campsite
you need to come up with we need to come
up with a name for the horse oh my gosh
so much pressure
it's too late we're at the campsite
or we could uh why don't we still
pressure
we can solicit uh see what people in
chat think and then we can vote on names
for our horse
let's let's give them some of the
attributes of our horse precious
wonderful magnificent glorious all of
these things beautiful rock
like rock like huh
rock type horse yeah like heavy metal
yep
uh that
those are all the attributes of our
horse that you should keep in mind when
naming our horse mystery that's pretty
good i love to read rainbow dash
shrek
sarah noodles sarah noodles sarah like
sir like
ah
noodles
i like that one brad shoemaker john
maxwell pumping house
butt stallion but but stallion timmy
black beauty glue
butt stallion with two t's fluffy buns
pressure is good boss happy bean
magic b or debbie wow that's stallion
cedric longbottom
that's a lot of choices
iron horse electra epona sarwini
herbert
butts italian butter cakes
the rest of the stream became horse
names they're all really good dwayne
johnson oh dwayne the horse johnson
dwayne the horse jones is really good
what is over here what did i mark with
my eye oh yeah riff time
horse bro
i mean butt stallion is definitely the
most repeated name yeah well that's a
borderlands reference oh eat it you
skinny horror i hate those things they
creep me right out
whoa oh no that's not my whirlwinds uh
all right so what do you pick i i named
all the options for you there was so
many options
ser noodles was really charming but it
feels like it's a little too silly uh as
his butt stallion
to sort of fit wayne the horse johnson
was pretty good horse johnson is pretty
great
people also liked pressure
the oncoming storm ooh
ooh
that fits really well this is a freaking
guy oh that is that's telling you right
ow
you
demon that's a lesser terror
boom
oh do you see how it got up that was
creepy as hell
just knocked me over
all right
i like the oncoming storm for our horse
name what do you think sounds good okay
that is also the title of our first
album
yes
and then we can use a horse picture for
the front of our album
with makeup on
like ours do you think there's horse
makeup yeah vegetable dyes safe for
animals you know
you close the rift good job i wasn't
paying attention because i was too busy
getting horse names that's fine
enhanced long shot
oh that's a good horse name too
enhanced long i think fire essence is
actually the i think the better off
enhanced long shot would be the title of
our first song on our album
enhanced long or is that like the b side
of long shot
like we have a track that's long shot
and then we have enhanced long shots
like the remix
exactly
i'm going to put that on to
uh varric because i think his ability is
long shot
accessorize there you go
buddy he looks pleased
low health hustle loss
why don't you just drink a potion
that is a really good potion noise uh
they asked me to do the sound effects
for this game but i i declined are you
busy yeah
damn but i'll give you a taste of
something that's a pretty good
opportunity yeah but you know
who needs sound design when i can just
make the sounds myself
oh asterium these things are kind of
neat they're like little puzzles
uh
i like puzzles it's just up the hill
there
i think you can climb up that grassy
place i think i can too
the real question is
can
the oncoming storm climb up that grassy
coast
oh look at his majesty
oh yeah oh yeah there's a bunny
i think that was a fox oh but i don't
want to i should have just let you think
it was a bunny because now you're just
thinking of the fox incident
technically they are fenix is the name
of the
oh what's up oh no bears or bears are
mean as well fighting the bear do you
see that there's like a mage or
something
oh dag yeah he's fighting the bear with
a book
i think that's an apostate mage yeah oh
what am i doing in here i should have
let that mage get killed
by a freaking bear hello will the mage
join us
oh god everyone just got killed by this
bear i'm running away i'm stone cold
running away from this fight immediately
will your teammates revive yeah once i
get out of danger they'll just show up
they just like shook their head and came
too and ran uh cassandra did you guys uh
could you not keep getting killed by the
bear cassandra cassandra
i need you to
run over here
what is the you can press a on the
ground yeah
away
there you go come over here cassandra
please advance time
run away from that bear
no you're going back
oh see like my dead buddies respond over
here
yeah no can we just all run away from
stop hiding that bear please run away
immediately from the bear oh god oh no
oh he's still here he wants you damn it
bear
i don't i can't call mohawk oh
maybe i should fight the bear a little
bit
you can beat him he's just a bear
just a bear
look at him look how cool he looks he
looks freaking cool as hell and he's a
friggin giant bear alright i'll give him
i'll give him the smash
uh cassandra cyclone can you i'm gonna
have to control you
to go do some revives revive
wow that smash was affected
oh wow yeah okay okay you taunted the
bear that was good
so that she can revive
oh nuts
why is he green wow is he rifted he's
got poisoned by varric
it looks like the same heart fog as the
rift
yep it's poisonous it's no good
all right everybody let's just get back
in this thing and fight a bear ow
this is not going well why is the bear
so strong he's really nasty we killed a
giant demon and we can't kill a bear
oh get countered bear
whirlwind bear attack oh oh wow crap
missed total mess talk about a whiff
solas can you please just get back and
do some spells against this bear
oh watch out
she's dead i know but like dead beyond
revival wow solas you went down really
oh i'm dead now is this better
running
is he gonna kill your entire party no
we're not we're not gonna wipe we're
gonna flee
lee
will you go away bear
i want to eat you real bad get slowed
down get poisoned
uh beefalo help me
duffalo ruffalo truffalo
bear oh sweet i think i got away
i think you smoked too soon
what no don't don't harvest the elf root
okay okay away from the bear
gotta keep the fence between me and bear
all right where are all my allies now
where can the dead bodies rain from the
sky
oh hey guys
you're asking me
they're alive
wow that was a bad scene huh yeah
let's never remember that that happened
i don't know what you're talking about i
need to go back to that camp
i need more potions
yeah we're almost here get your horse
you can go faster that's it we're right
here we'll get the horse to run away
from the bear
nothing
portions can you just replenish them all
please
all right cool nice uh so i can make
some of these just ringing my hands in
the bear situation yeah that was a bad
situation so you know sometimes you get
yourself into a bad situation oh well
james knack says stop er sign around
all right oh all right i like it a
little bear hair word please that's my
equine joke
best we best go now on our lupine
mission
what i don't oh yeah because we have to
kill walls oh damn nice nicely done
okay
with the bovine crowd
does that apply to bison ruffalo
yeah okay yeah that's yeah you're on a
roll man
unstoppable all right so there's like
the watchtower thing up
it's there gonna ride north and never
turn back this is back in bear country
that was a whole situation
look how beautiful the horse animation
is it's pretty nice
just like going on a real peaceful horse
ride through these valleys and you could
use dragon age that way you could just
use it like if you can't actually go
outside in the wilderness you could just
kind of go on a hike and drag it yeah
wander around look at some pretty
tactics this is
lovely a ram oh hell no bear i'll see
you later
yeah
who might interfere with nature aren't
you supposed to kill rams for food for
the village yeah totally
but i really just want to get some
scenery in here look at this it's me and
my horned brethren
oh what have we here
a camp
a deserted camp
it was called dead ram camp did it say
dead ram valley are you just trying to
get me to kill this friend said that
letter at an abandoned castle come to me
my love it's new lyrics this is new
lyrics yeah dreams have guiding you this
far
now i've read these words with your own
hand ew really what
for you to read when you hack
what
like here we go yeah yep you're gonna
just write the message because she's she
or he is sleeping and you're riding the
you are a creeper place is weird i don't
know about it i mean i will definitely
loot this chest what why did i get
oh don't tell me there's another bear
oh the horse disappeared all right bear
you're going down this time
bears are tough cookies man they are
they really are wow
i think i'm gonna die from bear again
we can't handle this bear we can't bear
it
oh god i need to revive this person nope
i don't need to jump
so let's get back in get back in the mix
oh you got him
he has like two health oh full nice i
have low health actually i should
drink a poach
i can't while i'm doing a smash warrior
widow 99 says level your followers did
we not
uh i'm in the middle of bear combat
right now i can't uh
i can't really
the chat named this winnie the pooh so
now it's going to be really sad when we
actually kill it
well that is
it is going much better way to go chat
this time
the bear is poisoned we have poisoned
winnie the pooh winnie the pooh is
panicking and fleeing in circles
i'm going to do a strike a mighty blow
against winnie the pooh
maddie pooh is chilled
it's not looking good
for old pooh bear
don't you try to run away
wow that last bit of health takes a
little while that was the unblockable
smash attack
one more for good riddance all right uh
so if this truly is winnie the pooh i
will find honey
jury's still out
could be one technically winnie the pooh
would have bear hide for sure
all right that was some good bear
slaughter uh i think we're gonna go now
and check out uh
new save game
and check out my other character
i think all the animals that i thought i
saw like bunnies and raccoons were just
those
what did you say it was fox fennica
switch characters
all right so uh
that was a look at sort of the first
two hours of dragon age uh you head off
into the hinterland start doing stuff
now fast forward about four hours
uh to my level four rogue elf named
elana
and we are gonna go to check out some
other areas
so let's see
some are bizarre at valroy oh that
sounds fun wanna go someplace fancy
i also want to fight something
don't worry there will be plenty to
fight maybe not in the fancy place but
later there are other places we can go
like the marsh place or the coastal
place just a nice uh sort of look at the
other environments
in dragon age inquisition because
like the hinterlands that was really
pretty that like nice little horseback
ride it was really nice
it was really really
no
we don't
uh
unfortunately i feel i guess i can live
without it now that i've had the glory
in my life at least well we're also
going to have to live without the glory
of horns
uh
you know you carry it in your heart
still but
you won't be able to look at it on
screen well at least uh so this
character's name is elana
yes alana so elana is probably um
i forgot our band name already
it's not the oncoming storm that's our
horse that's true
oh no it was we named it after our horse
so i thought that was our debut album
did we name the band i don't know if we
did no i guess we didn't
but anyway she's the band's biggest fan
is what i'm getting at she's a super fan
she knows all the songs she hasn't
memorized nice helmets yeah she's
wearing a giant helmet uh and this is
where i want to
make that helmet not
show so you can get to your face hide
the helmet
uh remember when we unhid the helmet
because we didn't we thought it was
gonna be horns yeah all right so this is
a lot of horns it was a happy story a
lot of great things happened to us
that's true
uh so a look at her skill tree it's
pretty archery focused so
uh i've doubled down on this long shot
which is just like a power shot so that
if i punch it through multiple enemies
it does extra damage to the ones it hits
and then uh
i also have this leaping shot which is a
sick backflip
nice
yeah backflips are sick you're gonna
when you see it
it's gonna be it's gonna be cool
oh do you think she's pretty cool
yeah all right she's got blonde hair
she's got elf ears she likes to look at
dead fish
examine
uh-oh what
i don't even know what's going on we're
down at the docks
we're down at the docks here in uh how
pretty valroy which is an orlais orlais
uh the other country
besides ferelden that you sort of
adventure in in dragon age inquisition
so this is the city
and
ain't it perte
do you want one i have my water bottle
thank you
this is uh revered mother havarra why is
she looking sick to her tummy uh cuz
she got punched why
because some templars got real sassy
templars man
so like this is a city where i walked
around and like
chatted with some people how pretty
yeah it's quite nice just gonna take a
quick look at it
oh it's lovely
i was before running around here trying
to find some secret messages
using my um
spider sense
and i found and they led me to this
secluded courtyard where i'm going to i
don't know it's called a friend of red
jenny i don't know what that is exactly
but we're going to go there after i walk
in this water like
some sort it's kind of sassy look at how
you walk
oh yeah
i'm the herald of andraste y'all better
wreck it yes
a different kind of herald than
us out of my way
i don't want to talk right now easily
agitated
all right so we're gonna hop
in the quest map to
a secluded courtyard to look follow up
on this quest
on these clues who are called friend for
people who are friends of red jenny
friends of red jenny that's our next
song
she's actually our writer she's not only
our biggest fan but she's our right wow
nice she does actually remind me of the
songwriter girl on the first season of
nashville here watch that show no i
haven't she's really blonde it's not
dangerous for you to be here make sense
out of this
oh snap this is the leader of the mage
rebellion she's like chief apostate
wow
she has a sick outfit otherwise
i dig that fur
right down at the end of the cloak is
that a tattoo oh yeah that's my face
tattoo
it's like a tree yeah that's really cool
the mages wasn't at the conclave
yes
you were supposed to be and yet somehow
you avoid crafted that armor for her
myself
you did with the menu
wow
you are quite the the armor smith i got
button pressing skills
i lost many dear friends that day
it disgusts me to think the templars
will get away with it
i'm hoping you won't let them
listen interesting question does that
mean the major finn paul asked do you
know if you can set your ranged weapons
and specialists
spellcaster to keep a distance in
encounters
because that would be helpful
an alliance could help to like yeah
retreat if someone's getting up in their
face yeah i don't know we'll we can
check that out i know that in tactical
you could tell them to keep a distance
what did she just say sorry i totally
damn it that was important i'm sorry
it's fine i'll run into her later
cool that was something something help
us something something i'll meet you
there i'm sure it'll be a waypoint i
think i played that part right right
before you got here and i think she said
my people are going to help you and
we'll meet
i think really
that would be good
do you know i can flip through these
cards
yeah why are they cards do you know like
what's the i don't know there's kind of
this whole tarot thing going on but like
even in the character selection screen
right it was those cards i think it's
just kind of a neat way to like
bring that the kind of cool art style of
dragon age make it more
legendary
it's pretty legendary
that's not the word i was looking for
but i stuck with it you know it worked
sometimes this is better choose a word
oh it's night time this this is yeah see
this is where i was when you came in you
were like what what's going on oh yeah
so
this situation i can like go invis
you're stealthy get up to an elevated
position oh what this guy's up here
watch me just shoot him in the butt
oh wait actually what i want to do
is try to
do some double damage on these guys oh
so i'm going to stand right here
and hit him with the power strike yeah
so see it went through both of them
back flip away so can you stay stealthy
until you attack or is there a timer uh
there's a timer but it lasts pretty long
as you saw
eat it
so then i just kind of shoot oh god
where's this guy up here i also get a
bonus for like the reason i went up
those stairs initially was because i get
a bonus for oh uh shooting from an
elevated position yeah
wow i'm i'm popping off right now what
is going on
yeah
that
is definitely an effect we're going to
have to use in our music videos
absolutely she's just testing it out
anything new boxes why are these guards
even here okay cool well you did it you
fended off the guards i fed the hell out
of those dudes that's a door that's uh
nowhere let's go in here
oh slightly more guards oh
damn whoa
how whoa did you expect to discover who
is this sassy fellow
weak in the inquisition they dress
strangely in order i don't know who you
are
you don't fool looks like a jester
i'm too important for this dude
oh
arrow in my
face it's just gone awesome
let's see this must be red jenny and
you're an elf
well
i hope you're not
too healthy
oh man that was great
some believe i'm the herald of andre
she's my sister from another mister yeah
what's this about
no idea you guys do look a little alike
my people just said the inquisition
should look at him
your people
elves
no
people people name sarah this is cover
get round it oh for the reinforcement
that's sarah not red jenny someone
tipped me their equipment [ __ ] i wonder
if that's her nickname or something
did she say something about people not
having pants yeah she definitely
we're now fighting pantsless guards no
way
look at this dude has no pants i mean
he's totally dead this guy has no pants
why don't they have pants
oh gross
he's covered in poison and he has no
pants
what have we stumbled into she stole the
crate of their stuff look at this dude
he looks ridiculous come on
oh my goodness sarah you cheeky little
this is awesome look at this she's like
got her [ __ ] game face on too look at
this
let me get down in here sarah
oh yeah i think you're funny because you
have no pain take that no pants man
wow
this
this is wonderful
all right i like sarah i like her a lot
oh yeah she can be invited to join the
band oh yeah she i think she would
definitely be a great onstage presence
perhaps she is the drummer and logistics
expert
like stealing pants
oh who wants to get back flipped all
right he's dead
does she just yell butt butt butt that's
what the cat that's what the subtitle
said no way really back me up chat
it said but
no three times
i want to know you're a strange one
i'd like to join
i would i just want to say yes yes 100
times yes
first you have to make sense i guess but
i don't want you to make sense you make
such glorious nonsense
you know
we need to get to know each other first
one name no wait two it's
well it's like this
i sent you a note to look for hidden
stuff by my friends
the friends of red jenny that's me she
was red jenny you knew it all along
there were three in stark haven brothers
or something oh they're all red jennies
it lets little people friends be part of
something while they stick it to nobles
they hate
so here in your face i'm sarah the
friends of red jenny are sort of out
there then you want to see but
to help you
plus arrows
don't think so i think nobody nobody
backed you up
can you provide noble allies you can
provide soldiers you're offering spies
it sounds like she's offering spies
the inquisition has spies i think you
imagine the butts but i'll watch the
vote oh no i definitely did not imagine
it let it be known that at 105
approximately
the butts happened
it did say butts
what are your widow 99 oh why your widow
you backed him up
or was he one of the little knives that
makes sense because she stole her pants
all those secrets and what gave them up
some house boy who don't know shite but
knows a bad person when he sees one
we're getting stories i'm not knife you
shiv dark all hidden if you don't listen
down here too you risk your breaches
literally
look do you need people or not i want to
get everything back to normal
like you
yes join yeah all right i've always
wanted you to investigate options we
don't have to
why ask if i glow
no fine yeah you're in all right sarah
i can use you and your friends
yes getting good before you're too big
to life that amount of reach is where
they should be yeah
breeches because i have all these you
have merchants you buy that fish yeah
got to be weathered
anyway
not only is she great at arrows she also
comes with a crate of pants that we can
use to help clothe the inquisition she
can sell the pants she stole
all right sorry varric you can only have
you can only have three people so
we're gonna
sit varric on the sideline for a minute
because
like that would be too many rogues
what his chest hair
do you want me to look at him you can
bring him his card is focused on his
chest hair it is
oh i didn't even notice that all right
no i'm just doing it we can we want to
bring the chest hair that's okay it is
kind of like a two-for-one thing you get
varric and it's chess it's up to you but
that is double archer and i don't know
all right we're gonna yeah we're gonna
stick with that
red jenny inquisition needs bees
operation available did you just see
that
all right we're going to go find out
about this whole operation thing
that's a big loop bag does it have pants
in it
too many breeches it does it has all the
pants in it
it just says too many i would like to
take too many breeches
yes i wonder how much space that takes
up in my inventory all right we're out
of here we got a new friendo
uh these are some different quests
so this is grand enchanter fiona that's
who we met before has offered an
alliance with the rebel mages at red
cliff so we're going to return to haven
and talk to the war council alliances
are good that that pr strategy working
mm-hmm
i want to go back to the world map
please
quest map
oh all right fine you want me to be so
excited i hope she i hope pants stealing
is one of her abilities
how amazing like she can just rock like
take the pants
and it's like a stun because they have
to like
get their pants back real quick
all right haven we gotta return to haven
here we go
i can't believe had okay that was so
good they weren't just so good when
games like this have a sense of humor
it's not just all like angie
she yelled butts butts butts
i
yes we're gonna have to get a screen cap
of that and send it around twitter uh
if any of you are watching the gamespot
stream you can just straight up scrub
back and find it yes you'll be able to
tell where it is because it's me
exclaiming in delight butts butts butts
it was approximately
six minutes ago fantastic
uh so we are going to go
i don't want to like get into two i will
have to get into a brief conversation
but uh from the the sort of
from haven where you're in the looking
at the world map you can do these
operations which are basically you send
your um
your sort of allies and agents to do
stuff and that just happens like 15
minutes later
so it's it's kind of like side stuff
that like increases your power or gets
you new assets or stuff like that
it's just kind of like a one of these
things that helps uh increase the sense
that you're like marshaling this big
force and that the inquisition becomes
like uh
yeah thanks i appreciate that
it's such a different herald this than
than oh yeah
it's a whole different scene
this is the diplomat lady yeah we met
her
my agents in a city sent word ahead of
course
it's a shame the templars have abandoned
their senses as well as the capital
what kind of character have you been
doing for
pretty nice pretty nice person pretty
straightforward and earnest uh
but definitely like not
not above a
little tongue lashing if people get
sassy
yeah we had this whole encounter with
lord seeker lucius it was a whole scene
a whole scene
very odd
we must look into it i'm certain not
everyone in the order this guy's a
templar but he's on my
advocating the side like going to the
templars right
i'm a little conflicted on him though
for this reason
those shoulder businesses you don't like
the shoulder business i think it looks
pretty metal myself
all right which one mages templars
i don't care you guys choose well you
could stop bickering and make a decision
i agree
we shouldn't discount redcliffe
yeah cassandra approves
yeah
but more desperate than that scarface
there's always danger
that face tattoo is so legit i know is
that a scar on your forehead i think
there's a little scar yeah i didn't
actually like it was one of the default
it was one of the sort of default faces
i tweaked it a little bit but not too
much
um
i didn't spend the long hours that we
spent at the beginning of the stream uh
messing around with
raven avatar pig taylor swift
oh the shortest lived inquisitor of all
other options
cool good talk guys oh liliana's got
something to follow up with there is one
other matter i just want to speak to you
the grey wardens are ferelden
great wardens
but they have also disappeared those i
recognize from previous dragon ages the
grey wardens
yeah
look at her inquisition bling yeah she's
all about that branding she's the brand
manager for our movement
why tell me
what's the point it's because
the others have disregarded my suspicion
but i cannot ignore it i need to get
some swag i need some inquisition swag i
like her her like cowl too
if you have the asymmetrical oh yeah it
comes down and then it's
attaches there the asymmetry i don't
think i've noticed that before
high fashion got a good eye for fashion
yeah this is the high fashion campaign
the other one was rock metal campaign
this is high fashion
all right let's poke our heads in the
war council area
we're gonna just take a quick look at
the sort of uh
sending people on operations so you've
got uh the diplomat lady liliana the spy
lady and cullen the soldier guy and so
that like each three of them has um
there's different they're sort of have
different strengths so for example what
we were doing when we scouted in
ferelden when we went to see mama
mama yeah so we chose this but some of
them like ferelden
like these these bigger pieces are
locations you can go to well that's i'm
not ranked but look at the title of this
inquisition needs bees
what does this mean
let's find out
a man who teaches how to draw them safe
but angry stingy no good for honey but
great for throwing he's somewhere this
is amazing sarah has also scribbled a
jar of bees hitting someone in the face
also a butt
sarah is the bomb
sarah you're my best friend oh my
goodness uh all right so which so you
then you can choose like all right
should i send cullen
he says like his response lets you know
kind of how apt he's like it's too large
to cover we should use bounty hunters
not our soldiers leliana says
uh
if this guy's selling bees to fighting
forces my people will follow the trail
um
and then josephine says i can send
runners among the bands if this weapon
can help it will be found josephine
sounds confident you down josephine yeah
all right and they each have like a
different time that it's going to take
them to do depending on i don't know it
depends it can be defrayed by like
agents that you get for each uh each
person
um so maybe liliano is the better one
because she has the oh no just kidding
it's like you know this is real time so
it's it's gonna be it'll happen before
the stream is over
uh it'll pop in there look look at red
jenny's banner
do you see behind the inquisition needs
bees oh my gosh making a cheeky little
geez
motion she is
sarah's cheeky bees
all right josephine take care of that
thank you
and then i think that i there's also one
over here called the van
there's a cult
this is a mission that i can
but so yeah what does it say
the cultists
there's some undiscovered passages in
this place that has their
relics with a concerted search effort it
might be possible to unearth something
um
yeah it seems like
seems like liliana's the one to go for
other than soldiers they're a little
craftier she's her spy spy ladies
and guys
uh
should go for that and then
this one is like always perennially
available to just like gather a coin so
like yeah go ahead cullen like you just
do that go wow an hour coins are time
time greedy time consuming all right so
we've been in the hinterlands so we're
gonna check out two more areas
uh i think we're gonna go first to
this place which is the fallow meyer
uh sarah's coming because she's
wonderful cassandra's coming because
she's wonderful
solas or varric
up to you all right let's go with solos
for a little bit of balance
and then
remembering butts butts butts
butts oh my goodness that's so wonderful
she sent you a note
that had a jar of bees hitting someone
in the face
also a butt
oh sarah bless you uh actually i think i
want to try to play as her because i
want to spe like i think i'm going to
get to choose what um
skill tree she has and i have two
archers already so i want to choose her
as one of the like stabby stab robes
given her obsession with butts i think
it's only natural to exploit that give
her a dagger to stab people in the butt
right does that say i mean you can say
that about any weapon
but i mean it's easier to cut off
someone's
breeches with daggers that's true goes
to
uh an arrow yeah so i think that makes
sense to me okay however however we want
to justify it
we're turning her into a stabby little
devil
uh choose the butt tree says uh angry
rob angry rob wants you to choose the
butt the butt tree all right
so flank attack you leap through the
shadows to attack your foe with deadly
strikes from behind that's what i was
using with my rogue last night you were
saying your rogue was more of an archer
i was using this one so what do you
think flank attack a good move
twins no
is what i had
i'm gonna get both okay because i need
some some attacks
perry quickly yeah yeah yeah you like
the pair i do like the parry uh so we'll
get that too
uh if their current health is lower than
my own i get a 10 damage bonus regain
stamina with every kill
i feel like maybe
before the target turns to face your
blow you move to stealth
impossible to find so i guess like
with this i stab them and then i go
stealth that sounds really helpful yeah
because
being up in the mix is going to be
you're going to be challenging yeah if
flanking
your twin fangs will keep
armor targets sundered from the blow uh
i'm gonna apply these
for now and i kind of want to check out
uh the actual stealth
tree because this is the one where i can
choose to just go stealth i think that
might be really helpful
um
yeah it has two stealthy chances to
dodge
enemies are likely to overlook you in
combat i feel like that will also help
so let's try those two
let's give it a shot see how it goes
yeah uh the question before we had was
about like the ai behaviors
it looks like um
so
basically
you can choose monon stamina like what
percentage to reserve that that's what
the energy it takes for you to use your
basic attack your targeting behavior
whether you're following the controlled
character or defending them
um
healing potion reserve where you just
don't
you don't dip that low
in your potions and i guess this is the
threshold when you're gonna activate
your potion
so
it doesn't seem like it gets any deeper
than that um and it's sort of the same
for all characters so
uh i remember in earlier dragon's age it
was
it seemed like it was a lot more in
depth but
here not so much
it's a little more streamlined i guess
that the tactical camera kind of makes
it so that you have that in real time
where you can kind of tell people where
to be and what to do all right i'm going
to take this weighted dagger
army dirk
she kind of reminds me a lot of harley
quinn
she does especially those tights or
leggings what would you call those yeah
leggings leggings
balanced daggers that's probably better
than the army
dirk right
weighted dagger is good but what's in
the what's in the offhand
uh balance dagger was 98 army dirk was
105 so now you may want army dirk
dirk
stiletto is 85. we're over 100 on both
of these i think so
we're just gonna go with that even
though stiletto sounds super badass
sometimes you just gotta go for the cold
hard numbers yep
offhand main hand wow nice looking good
stabbing time stabbings
need some armor
what armor do you have now it's a 56
rating
yeah that's pretty that's pretty solid
that's the best i can offer you have any
extra accessories
oh mercy's crest that's like a different
thing that's funny her armor right there
as opposed to the one some of the other
ones you scrolled through where it was
like a big coat with a scarf
this armor has the most points but it's
got openings like right here right on
her shoulders like right where you don't
want to be shot yeah as opposed to this
yeah it's just like bundle up it's cold
out there
all right let's get to it
yeehaw that's my sick backflip move all
right
sarah
dual daggers all right
damn
that was cool
all right so this is the parry b is my
parry
cool why is that backstab this is the
twin dagger leap stab
and then i have the invisibility thing
all right so this is the fallow mire
which uh totally sucks because it's
raining all the time and there's hell of
zombies
although the moon is pretty large
all right check that out
that statue looks
welcoming
you know what's welcoming
zombies zombies
what's happening zambies
oh eat it
oh you don't even know where i am stupid
zambia
yeah
get zammed
just give you some regular type stabs
now those zombies are quite emaciated
yeah they haven't been getting their
brains i guess not enough brains to eat
all right so walking through this area
is a little perilous because if you go
in the water like more zombies come out
oh really i have made a little bit of
progress though so i can fast travel
over to this camp and then maybe we'll
check out uh
this nasty stuff
not a fan of fallow myre
no but i mean it does look kind of cool
like it's really gloomy it's really
atmospheric it's
like really wet and gross
and i'm gonna go to try to stab some
demons
all right which where am i going here
fallow meyer should i go to this rift
this place was hard last time i did this
i got killed
but
got to defeat the demons yeah if at
first you don't succeed
try to steal the pants
they better be fine and the ones who
took them they won't be sure i'll take
this giant rock
i'll just put that in my my backpack i
want to go up here we're going to go
through the water but watch see if any
zombies come yep like instantly a bunch
of zombies spawn that'll be good it'll
be good practice huh i wonder why going
in the water brings that
because they live in the water oh
they're water zombies yeah
yeah
oh do one
water zombie and now i'm still stealthed
stab stab step
stab stab stab stabbing a lot
oh wow these guys are all low health
already
oh i love it
oh wow
how he landed
i'm not appropriate not
oh zombie comfortable oh no it's right
behind you oh anna look on the stream
it's on your head
oh no oh no it disappeared
why you put a zombie on my head man look
it was it was it just looked funny not
cool now she's walking on my head these
zombies
just like perpetually they must have
been doing that all stream
you've been sitting there
all right can you guys just kill all
these zombies and then we'll just not
walk in the water again let's go up here
this is where so these weird like totems
in the in the marshes
uh where you
light the fires
and then all the zombies come
and try to kill them and it's is that
what happened last time that you died
yes
oh what my potion situation is dire this
is a
low-end potion situation oh nuts all
right well who was this so that's region
like naturally no
no we do not all you guys just gruffle
down some regen potions
is that a real word no
that's cool i like it though it's a good
one it's fun kind of that sound like
gruffle
gruffalo
i get it
all right everyone
regen a little bit and then we're gonna
take this on what time we got
it is 127. cool we got about a half an
hour left so i'm gonna take these demons
on we're to do it you're totally going
to win i feel it
positivity
streaming the the metal god
ross
ross
in carl ross's name oh that's right i
need to use the mage to do this solos
where are you at
good thing you brought him get this
party started
nope i want to be you
that's hot spots okay here they come
everybody be cool
no don't use your attacks prematurely
yeah all right i'm gonna go down and try
to backstab some of these guys
wow zombie archers
yeah
nice the other one just ignored you and
went to your buddies dead uh-oh
come on get up there oh yeah because
it's this huge jerk
this guy
oh he is he's a problem
his hands are not natural looking no
oh
that what no oh damn it i switched
targets
no target this giant dude
this one right next to me
stab stabbed parry
nope he's not coming for the strike yet
oh yeah he does that like teleport
strike it's super gross all right you're
dead you die
who else can i mop up how are we doing
celeste's dead yet he's pretty dead poor
solo why isn't he using a health thing
squishy little mage oh no who just died
uh it was cassandra that's bad news once
cassandra dies it all goes south solas
use a healing potion immediately
alana use a healing potion immediately
immediately
i tried to
stealth and revive cassandra where is
she
uh probably overnight that stealth is so
useful
all right and she's back
cassandra
look at her she's so look at her
portrait she's so beat up do you have
any health potions all right yeah use
one of these regeneration ones
uh at least and then
all right
i'm gonna try to
all right i don't need this part is this
guy dead i need to kill this corpse
or no this lesser terror
it's elite
i need you to flank attack that thing
do it it has low health
wow
that is scary looking it does look like
a xenomorph arnold
all right
yeah that's
whoa you leveled up
i think there's another wave
oh no that's just rifts totally did it
we did it i knew it i did it i told you
i felt it oh that was a bad high five
i'm sorry that's all right i was
overcome it's fine
now i can
do a weird thing
with
and i can get like my weird green torch
and then i can look at this thing
like read some runes
a strong feeling of bitterness
oh sorry
gross i'm just gonna wander around with
this thing now we need to go back to
this camp and get some more potions are
you not supposed aren't you supposed to
do something with the torch
just run around holding it why i don't
know
are you supposed to like candles or
something yeah i i was able to see the
rune because i had the torch gotcha
all right everybody just replenish your
potions
sarah regeneration potion
so i can
replenish all of these because i have
a metric [ __ ] ton of elf fruit
i've just been grabbing a lot of fruit
when i've been walking around you're a
pretty good looter
yeah it definitely
it's a little time consuming you know
you gotta you gotta put in the effort
you know you get it you get out what you
put in that's true like so many things
in life
you put in daggers to your enemies and
you get out
rams wool
slice of lightning
yes
i'm equipping that one right yeah
this is called slice of lightning i mean
come on
all right that would have been a really
good name for a horse too the slice of
lightning all right army dirk sorry wait
can i quit the slice of lightning yes
can you tell me about it again
plus five percent armor penetration
rare dagger
that's what i'm talking about all right
we'll spend a little bit more time here
and then we're going to head off to the
storm coast to finish up because ooh
storm coasts sound nice it is also rainy
there but
i like the rain oh what is that this is
like rotten rain oh this is a rift all
right riff fight down for a riff fight
we're gonna close it
we'll have to open it and then close it
i hope you don't come to life sky
watcher
what who's what bro
are you gonna join us
he looks like he's part of the band
but it's not my job his kin wants us
dead
oh he's like yeah so i'm here because
like a bandit
clan has abducted some soldiers and i'm
trying to get them back
uh so like what's up why aren't you with
the other obama
ava
never seen anything like it trying to
figure out that all in the world
i like how he's talking to her
endless what the sky is trying to tell
us
i don't know
um they're called theme rifts they're
called fade riffs i closed them no big
deal what the hell was that explosion
some kind of magic gone wrong place is
weird look at his
hammer whoa
that's brutal
two-headed dog can't you see the warning
she writes through the bird flops in the
air
interesting smells really muddy it looks
like a lot of birds have pooped on
and
him
how far you get
oh
why aren't you attacking us i thought
the avar wanted to fight me
our chieftain son wants to fight you i'm
called him when the dead pilot
writes to the
gods meant for the bleeding a dagger for
the dying oh he's like the shaman
but he's carrying a giant warhammer so
why
sometimes you need to wallop things
that's life i mean i suppose
someone's trained them well
they killed more of us than i thought
they would
all right goodbye hey do you want to
fight these weird ass things by the way
watch the water yeah i guess that's a
good saying to have when friggin zombies
come out of the water
uh okay
yes he is i'm gonna play right now i'm
gonna play yeah that was sarah i'm gonna
control my chara the herald my herald uh
elara now
because
she's the one who can do the fade
zapping i want to be able to do that
during the the fight
i like that it gives you
tactical feedback when you do get a
little rumbling yeah
immediately disrupt the rift
yeah come on buddy fight with us yeah
your big warhammer
stunned
you two up watch this oh no i don't
think i think that tree is gonna get in
the way
anyone else anyone else
uh
where are the other where are they
there's a bunch more
oh what is that
see that thing frozen
uh oh no don't hit me no oh it hit me
very slowly we're just trying to disrupt
the rift oh it's going to do it again
away
oh yeah nice
frost what is that giant thing oh no i
don't want any of it it looks like an
abathur
oh it's dead that's i think that's a
rage demon or something it's gross it's
not cool
shut this party down
no more rip no more rips no more roots
peace out rift
oh what you think about that giant guy
i think that was pretty good
hey i can't
it says beacons in the dark for your
mission but i thought it said bacons
light the bacons
defeat the demons what's up skywatcher
you wanna come with
hello goodbye all right
that's all you guys
yeah
all right what else we got going on here
on my quest map
is there like a camp no i think there's
only a few camps
uh
another demon thing beneath the mire
more rifts
you know what
let's go to the storm coast
okay i would like to see the storm close
all right
we're gonna go to
the world map
and take it to
take the house
we're gonna take it to the house take it
to the limit i'm gonna take it to the
limit one more time
one more time
that was three song references in one
sentence by the way that's pretty solid
thank you
it's all about rock and roll in this
stream chris waters
oh i get to choose which camp i want to
spawn at
um
how about the camp the one camp oh i
guess i can go
can i go there no
inquisition soldiers that's where i'm
gonna head
there
and i'm gonna go here
storms solitude we're going to the
cleaning house that sounds not that
exciting
clean i don't want to clean the game
well maybe i'm clean i'm going to clean
house
right
got it yeah i i smell what you're
stepping in
i haven't heard that one before really
no
well now you have i smell what you're
stepping in yeah i'm picking up what
you're putting down i've heard that one
no it's definitely not as vivid
because you don't
it's never a good smell it's not like oh
you stepped in some strawberries oh wow
oh this is wonderful that's so nice
what'd you what'd you step in is that a
vanilla vanilla
maybe some cookie dough
is someone stepping lavender in here
this place is just really relaxing you
could step in lavender there's a good
one that you could actually
trump in some lavender yes
uh all right some rose bushes that would
hurt but i could smell it
just to step in some roses yeah
all right we're all potioned up
we're gonna head
what's up bird
oh
yeah like that seagull action yeah it's
pretty robust
is that a seagull it looks like a raven
except seagull colored yeah well this is
a rave these are the ravens they're
these are like
it's pretty vicious they got like little
red highlights yeah these are metal
ravens meadows right
i carry your message
look on the horizon a red mohawk
oh what's up jerks you guys about to be
dead
cool i'm invisible no big deal
oh
double
oh i only hit the one guy not the two
sick backflips
is that just like a dodge yeah like it
would be really good to have her oh
you got clobbered eat it
ah that was hilarious i really like that
that was good oh yeah backstabbing
um
yeah that that is an evade and it's also
kind of like
this shotgun
because it
it like shoots and they kind of scatter
a little bit oh cool
it's pretty good is it supposed to be
like multiple arrows yeah it's sort of
this
yeah i don't know
yeah like because it's kind of magical
also
head up into the mountains here of the
storm coast
yeah it's magical it but it makes this
noise like
here i'll we'll do it right here
pretty explosive very nice
she's gonna want this terrain is so nice
it's rocky as heck the
ocean's right down there too
we're gonna we'll come back around to
the ocean
yeah it's definitely a a vigorous
high seaside sea indeed
i think i already i must have already
read this
beware of falling rocks i don't know if
rocks actually fall from here but oh is
that a little what was that little
creature it's a little piggy looking
bald thing
i shall slay it for you
no it's like a it's like a rabbit bunny
it is a bunny for sure yeah these are
bunnies for sure they have weird mouths
though and weird tails that didn't look
like a bunny tail we'll get a closer
look at one hopefully it's probably just
a bunny with like a weird spelling you
know because
they'll just spell it like
b y n n
io a bini
video
well there's only way one way to find
out what it's truly called
oh what's up buddy
everywhere
it is more true than you want to believe
i bet right who wants to think about
stepping on dead elves
she's so blunt and cheeky
she is she's getting sassy with solas
who's also an alpha i guess we're
rolling pretty deep yeah styles lots of
elves
all right um
just kind of off-roading right now
sick off
yep all-wheel drive no big deal
oh look a tiny path i will clean down it
and that yeah like that's the size of
the paths like all the exploring all
these environments has been
like definitely one of my favorite parts
about playing the game so far cool
it's so purty and so
dramatic
um i just have to take it to the limit
stuck in my head now
i'm trying really hard not to sing it
out loud nobody to blame but yourself i
know i did that all right what is this
situation i'm coming up on here
cleaning house uh i'll find the bandits
and deal with them okay so
one of the optional things for this
quest i think
was to
uh wear this particular
crest i saw that yeah wear this crest so
it's an accessory
mercy's crest cool just gonna put it on
and like challenge the bandit leader to
a fight i think
yeah challenge the bandit leader while
wearing mercy's crest
cool
i'm down we'll see how this goes because
i don't know one-on-one combat doesn't
really seem like the archer's purview
but is mercy a person or a
number or just a i don't know i think
virtue
oh yeah i got a challenge
oh damn
sweet graffiti though that's cool art uh
the whole bonesy thing is a little
creepy what are you gonna do
knock knock suckers
i'm wearing mercy's crest and i
challenge you that's right i don't walk
quickly
i'll get wrong where where are you the
world waits for me oh there you are oh
standing obviously over there by himself
yeah that must be him you're the leader
of what you and what bandit crew i don't
see anybody around here all i see is a
bunch of giant skulls way bigger than my
head
i wonder well maybe they were a cool
statue
so you would challenge the blades of
hisario
yes i would
let's chat
we don't have to fight no we definitely
have to fight okay
you killed soldiers of the inquisition
you're gonna die you want justice
claim it i will i will i will claim it
through your throat
oh you missed me sucka
what you're throwing dogs at me all
right this is not a one-on-one challenge
cool that's fine whatever i got homies
too
perceived
oh this dog is
a warrior dog
hello oh in your face
oh i'm in a fire i'm in a mild fire
that dog
do you think if i just straight up kill
this guy first the dog will get off my i
don't know
all right dog just just take it easy
all right i really want this to be a
penetrating shot oh i think i got a
couple of them very nice oh a little
shotgun approach boom he's burning and
he's frozen all his dogs are froze
eat it
definitely got him for sure he's dead
for sure compared to the bear
still
that's for sure
although i am a little higher level than
uh caras was potato potato
boom oh what that dog was in a bad
situation he's standing up on his hind
legs mabari hounds
tricks will save you now
play dead
be dead
that's a very
did you just go hide in a cage
it seems counterintuitive
it's safe in there i just want to go
back in my crate
look at they're kicking them around
oh get shot
is that thing dead yet man
didn't she say something up face
to play down right nice
now you get
loot
excuse me i'll talk to you in a moment
lou loot any corpse loot
they're at my service now oh yeah
the blades of hersarian oh wow that's
right
wow because if you kill their leader
then they worship you that's neat
you work for me now that should be a
question or an exclamation point yeah
you work for me now
to the inquisition
we're loyal to you
me that's right you can keep calling me
your worship too that's fine that's all
right i guess anything to report what do
you got what do you got what do you got
report
nothing of note oh
then what you think cool keep standing
out in the rain
i do know where to find you
so that so like agent acquired now this
dude will like
they're on they're on my team now
they'll like boost the
there's a horse can you take it
a bitter note
oh
this is
contraband now that we are yeah no that
must be destroyed
feed it to the horses hello
oh horse why can't you be mine so close
and yet so far
look i'm just like you
hang out where did you come from
cassandra
i was just hanging out back here i know
i know i'll get us a horse sometime
later i want it
all right let's go to the coast
because last time i was at this coast
some crazy crap was going down i want to
see the ocean all all in turmoil
the ocean
will be heaving
heaving swells i tell you is that does
that go in the romance novel with the
thrusting long sword yes absolutely all
right this is straight out of varex
playbook man we have done so many things
we've written a romance novel we started
a band
a metal movement i dare say
we got a horse listen we're going to be
productive on streams all right here we
go
the waking sea
man i would sit and stare at this for a
while
go for a swim oh no
i can't swim very well wow apparently
not you insta can't swim
i
needed to be fished out
all right
uh so last time i was here hold on let
me check my saves because last time i
was on this coast
there was straight all right i'm gonna
load this up again because there was a
straight up dragon like popping off over
here dragon we have to see a dragon
before the end of the stream let's see
if i can we only have 12 minutes you
find death driven you find it
yes ma'am
frost back mountains that's like
brokeback mountain but with ice
this is why would i be in the frostback
mountains that's like the first place
you go
valroyo milestone frostback mountains
auto save the storm coast that just
happened i'm gonna go here i'm gonna see
what's going on
this seems like the maybe the place that
i was or something
arnold i can't make any promises folks
but i'll try
you guys everyone send good dragon vibes
to chris waters so we can find a dragon
to
that's a really cool last name
pentaghast
especially with the g-h-a-s-t
adds a little extra
ghoulishness to it yeah like a ghast but
penta like she's really cassandra
pentaghast you're aghast five times over
yes
not just triple gas
no not even quadruple gas
quad gas would not be gas
pentagas is way cooler
trigast kind of cool
cooler than quadrogast
i'm saying bye gassed
duo games
digast all right
uh
let's
go
back to the storm coast
yeah
all right i think it's going to work
yeah because you only have these three
sorry sarah
she can't make jokes about stealing
dragon's pants
anna
you're gonna have to pick up the slack
okay dragon pants dragon bands dragon
butt jokes the whole thing
that's what i expect dragon buds
the valuables category in your inventory
contains loot you can sell for profit or
items you choose to move there valuables
can be sold quickly to merchants like
pants
stolen pants
too many breeches
two ready pets too many breeches oh man
my job is butts and pants jokes my mama
would be so proud so proud
mama i'm making a rock album what'd you
do on stream today well i said
butts in a row like a lot of times
yeah
fidget games
i'm not sure i don't think this is the
first time in this okay so this means
it's the first time i've gone to the
storm coast
because uh this lady is welcoming us
again with her sexy freckles she does
have great freckles also a little bit of
blue eyeliner
because this is the height oh i forgot
about high fashion we also did that yes
yes
really nice little blue under eyeliner
there
it looks like it's pink or something or
like inside the eyelashes it's like
right here oh
okay
thanks thanks for the report someday
we'll do a makeup tutorial stream for
you of course
uh
i think people would watch that for sure
but they were starting their search
farther down the beach
with all this fuss we haven't been able
to conduct a problem
either
well
good luck
and enjoy the sierra i hear it's good
for the soul she always seems a little
nervous yeah i know i think she's like
like she's a little starstruck yeah
exactly she's a fan girl of you the
herald all right my potion situation
did you hear that
all right actually alright get out of
this thing because if you heard a dragon
then you can see a dragon look at that
look at it
oh
dragon
is it did it kill you before i did not
engage it before but it will almost
certainly kill me this time sweet what a
way to go out but it won't stop me we
only have eight minutes so you gotta get
killed by a dragon in eight minutes
i accept
you
viking ship beached on the shore yeah
this this this is a good better look at
the coast too because like look at these
like the stones are all kind of smooth
like sea tumbled rocks are it's got
these big like driftwood logs which like
seems to me like is kind of a pacific
northwest thing yes that's exactly what
i was thinking i'm gonna read this ocean
book real quick i don't know
no we would rather sing about uh
viking boats and seeking the dragon for
a doom befitting this is definitely
another good place for a music video yes
perfect setting i feel like we need to
make this and just cut a game play and
like some majestic sweeping like
like this this is our like our album
cover art is just us standing at
different levels on on these rocks come
on guys this is get in the picture like
like queen you know yeah in a point see
varricks into it so let's come on
all right we got
trying to get up we gotta find a dragon
i seek the dragon
what is that no no time for picking
plants
no time for picking pants
look there's even like giant majestic
statues
i steal pants i don't pick plants
oh we don't have sarah
don't have to go through that cave with
the spiders no i can just skirt it
there were spiders in there oh yeah
there's giant ass spiders in this cave
did you want to see them no i want to
see the dragon okay my control is
rumbling right now because i see if i
see low in the distance
there be a dragon wow who's it fighting
that's a good question
and i think this is where the uh whole
butt situation is gonna really come into
play really because it's like a giant
ogre man look at that thing whoa
we're going right over there oh my gosh
we need to we're going to observe from a
distance first first look at all the
loot you're passing up in the name of
this quest i'm focused
don't get killed
don't get killed
like look at how cool that dragon is oh
it's coloration orange
it's yelling
wow whoa whoa
that was some good old dragon age
physics right there
no big deal just hanging out by a beach
biking ship where a dragon and ogre
fighting this is definitely a scene for
our music video right there i'm alara
reporting from the strong coast here
where a dragon is locked in combat with
some sort of giant tusk oh come back
here no
no get back his waters
you were supposed to get killed
what about getting killed by this giant
ogre dude
don't worry i can do one damage to his
knee
immune
why why does he keep spitting out immune
because he's probably immune to spells
and stuff
oh come on shred this guy's acl
three points of damage at a time
looks like he has had bad posture for a
long time yeah
also like not a real healthy diet i mean
he seems strong and all but like
his skin's rather sallow
does he have tusks
yeah he definitely has tusks that's cool
i mean we're just kind of assuming it's
a he right now that's true it could be
she you don't know what kind of genitals
these giant ogre beasts have i'm not
checking either and i'm not
i'm okay to not know oh you got to get
away from that oh yeah that was a crit
critical hit to the knees
eat it
who's dead
oh solas is dead
i should probably go revive him
see inside the ocean
oh yeah curious oh
oh solace
you can't lay there
you'll be grounded i need to be like
up here i want to be on the boat nope
can't get on the boat must resume
shooting troll thing can you target one
of his knees more than another no i'm
trying oh we might take this thing down
we're doing pretty okay he's like down
to a third because he's only cassandra
stays alive
uh
that's not enough that doesn't look good
all right hold on cassandra
could you please oh she's taking a
healing potion god bless you cassandra
you truly are wow truly are a warrior
that close up on the ogre
here go tactical so we can do a close-up
on him oh you want to knee
oh he's down
hold on all right yeah we can we can
check out check him out while he's down
first off all right yeah cool
all right oh was that telling you you
could scroll between their targets yes
so i can target his legs
uh i can target his large hairy butt
ogre
oh
oh my god look at his face is he a
cyclops he's definitely a cool oh well i
don't know yeah wait yeah definitely
look at that it looks like he has eye
sockets
on
they're just like high cheekbones
weird damn you ugly look at those teeth
those do not look functional no i mean
unless you were eating something really
big
even then i mean like i mean
you're trying to like how do you even
that's why he doesn't have a nose
maybe he doesn't have some molars or
maybe he's just got real strong like
stomach acids
it's unfortunate man and we're also
gonna kill you which is also unfortunate
it's definitely going to kill you oh
that's shield smash
yep cassandra's all up in there
all right finish him
finish him
on the shore
bother your shirt at the head
maybe we finish the ogre
we strike down the giant
all of us together in harmony
wow oh he is almost dead that's nice
oh get it i don't want to be dead i'm
throwing rocks at you
i'm so mad about what's happening right
now
solas will you eat a health potion
yeah
whoa and that oh he's falling into the
water
don't
you'll need to be more specific there
where's where's the giant
flute you're not
uh well
it's 159. all right so
we can wrap up or i could like reload
this save and try to run and get killed
by a dragon
you know
we saw the dragon if we saw the dragon i
think it's better to like let it live in
mystery and also end on the triumphant
kill of the giant i think you're right
because then
for people who are watching they can
experience that for themselves yes you
too can experience getting mauled by a
dragon in dragon age all right here we
go everyone come on will you guys just
get into the freaking po photo here
okay come here come on come here form up
remember
solas is being hella emo and just not
even
all right let's can we just like duck
all the hud elements real quick
hud visibility
none
always off
yeah just get get everything off
yeah oh dang it
let's see will that how much will that
reduce woo
wow okay let's get our shot we'll close
it down
yep eric faces
you can't be
i'm in the front guys i'm in the front
that wide pan epic
all right
would it be better for the difference
and there they stand
our mighty heroes waiting to fight
another day shepherded us through much
of the dragon age inquisition live
stream no bear could take them down
indeed they vanquished them as they
vanquished all who came at them except
for that one bear who killed them all
that time yes that one time but we don't
speak of that we will never speak of
that or the fox internet uh big up to
karas for uh being a real beautiful
qunari and a pretty big two-handed
badass uh thanks to all you guys who
watched and chatted on twitch and on
gamespot it was a lot of fun yeah thank
you guys for all the the feedback and
the input that was great it's fun to
play with friends absolutely hell yeah
chris waters yeah thanks for
watching my pleasure uh couldn't have
done it without you couldn't have let us
you know you really led us in spirits to
sort of
broaden our musical horizons
really just
suck the marrow out of dragon age
inquisition
uh the game comes out on tuesday if
you're curious about it our review is up
on gamespot check it out kevin give it a
nine it's pretty excellent uh i'm
looking forward to playing some more
yeah tell me what you guys think tweet
at us and let us know what what
adventures you get into and whether you
find any heavy metal moments as well oh
yeah definitely metal moments from
dragon age inquisition we're into it
alright folks thanks for watching see
you next time
you